you welcome everybody happy Friday it is
March 3rd
yes yes
warming up a little bit here on this
beautiful Friday afternoon thank you
everyone for being here today
yes today we have a um
fantastic episode everybody loves the
tournaments this one's been stewing for
a couple weeks now it is Clash of the
Titans
the green screen tournament and boy have
we got some great entries I'll be honest
I've watched I was intentionally trying
not to watch them because I wanted to
get my genuine
reaction but the few that I have seen
are incredible as I thought as I
predicted there are some insanely
talented folks in our audience who are
gonna be on full display today
yeah why that one you said watch I don't
know I like that sound don't get me
wrong yeah trying to usually I can
connect them in my mind but that time I
had a hard time I was just taking it
somewhere else I appreciate that
uh first place gets 500 second place
gets 300 three and fourth get one
hundred dollars it's all happening today
I'm very excited
I'm also super excited we've been
talking about this a lot it's kind of an
aside but of doing the H3 lore series
we're going to be doing
my plan initially is to do one video
on either like a person or a topic or a
meme that explains the
she's at home
she was going to try to make it today
but this morning she just wasn't her
throat she's got throat stuff both the
kids were sick I haven't gotten sick yet
but I know how this [__] goes I always
get the sickest of everybody
somehow nothing yet
sick although my neck is killing me bro
I have like no range of motion oh
I could go to the Cairo
I need I need someone does anyone have a
mallet they can slam my spine with yeah
I have a Melody is that why the other
day you kept saying ow wow is it your
neck oh yeah it's been hurting for a few
days
I woke up and I just had this incredible
uh
how do you call it
cramp
like right here and my neck he doesn't
exist
no I have a neck it just hurts
um yeah you do that's why you're a [__]
I'm a [__] ass Nick neck having [__]
yeah he was at home
and actually we did um we're doing the
egg retrieval tomorrow
which is what I've been giving her shots
every day
last night we had to give her a shot at
exactly 2 30 a.m
and she needs to take another one today
at exactly 2 30 p.m I'm gonna message
her my alarm is going to go off
and um
then tomorrow we're gonna get them eggs
and scramble them up with some keys baby
I hear eggs are way up right now and I'm
gonna take a dude I gotta go to that
curse room and nut at 8 A.M tomorrow
like that is just way too early morning
uh morning love
bro it ain't love what goes on in there
ah I was like bro come on I mean I have
my coffee yet I gotta jerk off
Gabe speaking of Friday there's my boy
it's Friday baby you're sideways Bud oh
there you go
there you go yeah we're just gonna say
hold on one sec I was just gonna say
we're doing the lore series
which I'm super excited about we'll be
doing it on a topic a person a meme that
we think is a key lore development the
whole purpose of this is so that we can
get new people in on
the podcast give them some kind of guide
so that'll be posted to the main Channel
and
uh starting next week uh will be our
first one I'm thinking for the first one
shout out to the family as for example
another one could be on a crew members
Genesis it could be
on Gabe will definitely have his own
lore video for example so
all right I'm looking forward to say hey
Gabe what's going on how are you on this
beautiful Friday
all right it's good I'm trying
underneath it I'm gonna try some sushi
baby okay okay you you have a good sushi
spot in La you like
well midori's please
yeah bullies
[Laughter]
I'm gonna try the California roll of my
first time
oh wait you've never tried Sushi you're
you're you're [__] with me Gabe last
week it was you never tried coffee now
you've never tried Sushi is that
I'm gonna try this one if this is good
is he is this really his first Sushi by
it according to Nick yeah
wow
he seems like such a he's not feeling it
he's not feeling it
yeah
he's gonna swallow it good man okay I
think it's a lot better with a little
soy give me a little soy sauce on there
because otherwise it's just really Bland
and you know what I mean yeah in Japan
in Japan nobody
sushi would choices in Japan it was
cleaner
say what
in Japan nobody eats um Sushi without
soy sauce in Japan they don't eat it
without soy sauce they eat it without
soy sauce you're saying they don't use
that can't be true can it well I'm just
curious how he's dropping knowledge
about you you this is your first time
eating sushi yet you know so much about
it
exactly all right do they really eat not
use soy in Japan we're gonna add Swiss
on uh when it comes back next week well
just Google it because I need to know
right now it says I want to go into a
primary source it's it's I'll ask him
it says that uh they do use it they they
do use it in Japan Gabe what's your
Source on that information regarding
misinformation
I'm asking Hassan right now who's in
Japan is there soy sauce
sushi places
and Japan
so well but okay that's interesting
factoid but it's uh yeah yeah it's my
opinion oh it's your opinion
in your opinion nobody uses soy in Japan
right
okay so so you really trying sushi for
the first time this is so interesting
yeah and what why in your 50 long years
of life why have you never thought to
try sushi
um I don't know I'm just skeptic about
it now it's my first time I mean I I
that's what I try but I'm not I'm not a
fan of it did you say
uh look can I can I ask you a question
Gabe yeah didn't you say that this was
your favorite sushi place
favorite Sushi's place but I don't eat
sushi I order like beef ribs and stuff
okay okay cool my man all right so
you're gonna go in for another one
yeah I'm gonna try to summon sashimi soy
again
no soy oh sandwiches
just straight raw salmon bro that's my
favorite way
why are you doing that
let's try it you're supposed to eat it
with the sushi no no no no I mean
Sashimi oh yeah so why are you guys
eating
I'm not a fan of it yeah yeah we're
gonna find the rust of the raw do you
not like um do you not like soy sauce is
that what's going on there I like soy
sauce but with meat
s tradition in Japan it's not though
yeah it's not tradition in Japan though
Gabe it's just a fact no you can use the
soy sauce it's okay you won't be
disrespecting soy sauce comes from Japan
I don't think I'm getting through to you
all right Gabe listen
I love you man thanks I appreciate you
doing those first
those firsts with us coffee Sushi I love
if what you got anything else planned
for the upcoming weeks that you have
never tried before
maybe you can uh
go ahead we're on a couple couple's date
and next week I have salsa salsa dance
next week
are those on Friday are we gonna get a
preview of those oh maybe hey I'm Frank
hey if you do salsa dancing can you have
Nick call in and and record you I'd love
to see that
sure oh yeah
hey I know
I know what you can call in and do for
the first time
what is it going down on a girl stop she
said oh no
well I was just hit the button lots of
Firsts we have lots of Firsts here for a
game a lot of first times for everything
that's my first time
would get us demonetized so quickly
I don't think that's the first we can do
how's that everyone get in trouble yeah
no let's not do that you guys are right
hey um
did you ever uh follow up with that girl
that you've been on a date with any any
developments there
still working on it and we're improving
nice my boy you guys going down on dates
you guys are you guys talking every day
every few days
every few days every few days okay and
when's the last time you saw her
last week last week you guys have plans
coming up for next week or this weekend
the salsa dance and maybe a couple's
maybe at the movies he told you all this
a minute whatever she likes you can tell
me on this
when
that's how just a minute and a half ago
he told me that he's going on a couples
date and going salsa dancing oh but I
didn't I thought I yeah okay I didn't
put it together the couples date thing
well that's so exciting Gabe I'm so
happy for you
and do you get butter do you get
butterfly flutters when you are near her
uh sometimes I just gotta respect her
that's all of course my respect to women
always I can't like be aggressive no no
no no no respect respect and always ask
always ask
sure if you want to kiss her just ask
can I is it okay if I kiss you for
example is it okay if I hold your hand
do that let me hold a hand but I don't
know about the kissing yet no I'm doing
well yeah I'm just giving you okay well
that's exciting
do you feel nervous when you're around
her
um
that's for a few minutes just about to
get my confidence not get comfortable
that's nice
wow do you think
do you think the fact that you're famous
and successful is like uh something that
that like I think maybe interests you
about you no I'm not saying she's a gold
digger but she's like you have a lot
going on for you like you know you have
a good job
you're famous
um
she has to like me for who I am it's not
what I'm famous for it's who I am right
right if if I'm not famous for anything
and I'm maybe maybe if she likes me
she'll like me the way I am just gave
you're just gay yeah no way exactly
right does she like white claws
oh yeah she does so that's big that's
big all right Gabe I'm so happy for you
I wish you all the best with your girl
and on your dates I'd love and uh baby
[__] [__] of my [__] [__] under my
chin and [__] under my chin and put your
neck down on that [__] baby
hey [__] in my shoe and I'll wear it
like a sock [__]
shut up my shirt on my shoes and put my
feet in it
hey
um [__] in my gloves and put them on
like Vaseline baby
[__] on my head and put it on my face
[__] [__] cover my whole body and [__]
head to toe I don't want to see any
color just brown baby
brown legs baby
[__] yeah [__] yeah baby it's Friday
yeah baby it's Friday baby it's Friday
baby
have you sang that to your um
here's your love interest
yep once or twice she likes it okay
that's good
[Laughter]
I can't do it any longer Gabe you're the
best we love you have a great Friday
happy Friday buddy all right happy
Friday
[Applause]
it's Friday Friday everybody get down on
Friday
Lots going on in Gabe's life
killing it things that are happening for
Uncle Gabe
um
this shirt I thought would look cool but
it's really not flattering
look how it's hugging my [__]
my next shut up it's part of it yeah but
even still straightly straighten out
come on nobody even together if I exist
there you go it's still not helping you
see what I mean like what if you drop
the buttons down a little
I think yeah I should but I think listen
to Zach he had you looking good the
other day there was a H3 fan in Japan
rocking that shirt yesterday walked up
to Hassan on stream oh that's cool whoa
love that huh
all right
I don't know I feel like a dad when I
when it's buttoned down I like the up
it's like fashiony you know what I mean
you don't want to look like a dad today
you know what's funny when I was a kid
the full buttoned up look meant you were
a gang member you remember that of
course yeah that was
yeah
how did the gang members they got the
full button up how did they claim that
yeah yeah well there it is guys head on
over to teddyfresh.com it's our only
sponsor today
so chew on that
all kinds of good stuff man
you know what I'm saying
they're our only sponsors so give them a
good read recently you've been uh I'm
getting been playing around here
Olivia's actually rocking uh one of the
new jackets oh show that off girl
yeah this one is super
oh wait where's the jacket oh is that oh
here it is oh it's sold out I love it oh
well then still looks great it does look
great and uh you look great in it thank
you thank you also dude these bags are
so nice
um it's got this really nice gingham
Style
[Music]
and then it's got this like I don't know
what it's called but it's just so nice
to put together it's such a beautiful
piece the bags here lovely
and then um
one other thing you all should know
about is
uh
there's one other item you guys should
know about this Sherpa hoodie
classic beautiful colors looks and feels
amazing I'm not only available in extra
small I notice there's only two
remaining get it now no well you got
they got oh [__] there's only two of
these left [__] this sucks
I'm blowing it okay what about the bear
brooch flannel jacket surely there's a
few of these left
okay it's small medium large XL there
you go
yeah check this out guys boom look at
that comes with a little bear on it who
does that nobody
thanks
teddyfish.com
well it took a little that took a while
to get through
[Applause]
all right so I'm gonna do a few things
at the top of the show
but we really got to jump right into
this because we have 32 entries on the
green screen competition and this is
going to take a minute
yep to get through
um strap in
I'm so happy for Gabe though he seems so
excited and into it's so cool that he's
you know he's he's courting someone you
love bloom you know and we'll uh we'll
coordinate that's also lesson for oh
please bro I want to see him I got to
see Gabe you know
I want to see the hips
that's with the sauce have you guys have
you guys seen him dance did he dance at
his party
not the one that no one went to but the
the previous one that everybody went to
besides you besides me but I never said
I was going I'm just kidding uh he did a
little bit of a rock away a little bit
you know we saw him like jump a little
bit okay dude he's gonna assault oh I
can't wait for that but yeah um
you guys might see this I guess the
camera went up a little bit
my finger is on the button it's not
ready yet
Dan almost got it set up but on Monday
we'll have or well I don't know you're
waiting for another uh the parts that I
need are coming on Monday so probably
Wednesday
my finger is on the button what was that
song how's it going how does it go can
you hum it for me
my finger chemical is on the brother
on the button button yo I should can I
wear this like a necklace
that's uh
this is an expensive drip doesn't matter
it's like uh I mean Flavor Flav has got
nothing on this I will totally be down
to actually wear this like uh so the
sponsors always know
listen guys we're brand friendly and it
always goes off the rails don't worry I
got this right here right on my chest
because I'm making a promise I'll keep
it right over my heart
crossed my heart hope to die bring your
heart on your chest
we should make like a comically large
button that just presses that little
bottom and have it in the background so
you can just boom do that I think that
would be kind of cool break glass I
don't I think the sponsors might be a
little concerned if you have a device
strapped to your chest
it's not it won't detonate
if it does detonate Dan has a button you
could cut that
my fungir is on the button
yeah so um for the people asking I will
have the button too don't worry
don't worry this was crazy we all did
the um
the Goodwill Hunting somebody said that
it should have been Good Will Hunting
this is such a good title [__] uh but
somebody edited the Ethan bus on the
face and it's pretty [__] weird and
good
like holy [__] that works doesn't it
Ohio man
this is me ABS thanks baby you look
thanks bro
you're my boss Sandler core
Hollywood Knights the winner of course
and the country
Club it really works so
uh Hollywood Nights wasn't oh my bad it
was Florida that was the winner
yeah my bad here's the winner yes we
know sorry
apology damn
okay you know what you guys know that
Jeff Dunham passed me on Howie's podcast
well this outrage
cannot stand Jeff Dunham as we know is
insecure loser he taught he does his
jokes through puppets like if you had
any braver you would tell these racist
jokes through your own mouth coward
I oh I'm a spicy jalapeno
let me jump across the border and steal
jobs from Americans
it's like bro tell the jokes yourself
you racist
I kill you the Ahmed the undead
terrorist I mean have we not um
because these are all the ones that I
remember from like when I was a kid has
he not no hated the ACT no not at all he
got the same like the same damn puppet
go to his [__] go to his website it's
just Ahmed the undead terrorist and
chili pepper guy swear to God Jeff
Dunham here's the website he'd probably
make a trans puppet yeah look it's this
usual suspect right yeah yeah well I
didn't see the Ahmed maybe he dropped
Ahmed no there you go oh there he is
still not canceled
playing the hits man I mean dude you
[__] been telling the same jokes for
20 years brother
oh
baby do you find
Jeff Dunham's side uh yeah I'm more than
it being like extremely racist it's just
extremely unfunny which I find more
offensive to be honest yeah but do the
people of Dearborn do they know about
Jeff Dunham they're like this shit's
lame yeah they don't [__] with him yeah
we got a lot of ahmeds there too I mean
Lena's dad's name is Ahmed this is Ahmed
the undead terrorist I mean bro get some
new he's such a douche well anyway
I've been making fun of Jeff Dunham
basically my whole career online I was
gonna say is he
yes Enemy Number One really like of the
H3 Universe you know there's a clip of
him acknowledging me really yeah maybe
you can find it he's at YouTube Studios
and someone says H3 and he goes oh yeah
we don't talk about that guy
and that was like when I was small and I
was just making the Jeff Dunham [__]
puppets
and selling up
I'll see if I can find it
he needs like a trans puppet I'd put him
right on top
it should be like hello I'm here to
compete in women's wrestling
itself
I'd be the best right-wing grifter I'm
telling you I would clean it up not
seeing anything come up when I search
it was really obscure maybe you guys can
find it but here's the problem
Jeff Dunham passed me on how we show
now his
his clip his video with 550
000 over half a million views has only
459 comments
now if you go to back over to you know
the
the rightful uh top viewed episode with
almost you know 485 less views
by about seventy thousand
mine has 6 300 comments
um interesting topcon
yeah thank you for saying that
so I'm just saying there is you there's
a usual kind of
ratio of comments to views that kind of
shows what a real video should be
getting and this one of Jeff Dunham's is
way way way below
now I'm not saying Jeff Dunham bought
views but I am saying it might have been
uh peanut let's go yo may have been his
puppet Peanut
shut up this is it shout out blizzard
Woofy you guys dude blizzard messages
yeah we know about these guys
[Laughter]
dude how do you even show your face you
can cut it
you should literally
you should just be bullied when you
leave your house
I mean you're a ventriloquist bro get
your [__] together I mean come on this
that's an ancient art form
what a talented out there
I was bullied for my Ahmed puppet
because I had a red hair
oh that [__] kills me
yeah and that was like way back in there
when was that posted
um in
says five years ago 2017. so I wasn't
even really
a big deal like I am now now I'm a huge
deal no March 2017 you would have been
you think I was a bigger deal maybe
maybe yeah maybe it was around when the
podcast started oh yeah that was big I
was big time then that's what I'm saying
I was a hot shot then he knew oh boy
yeah so I'm I don't know like
go to for example Bobby leaves who is a
very funny comedian great guy he has
half the amount of views that I have
he's been in the comedy game for a long
time and I still get double the views
that all being said
what how many comments does Bobby's have
it has a thousand three hundred and
eighty five a thousand three hundred and
eighty-five interesting how is it that
Jeff Dunham has over double and he has
459. it does not make sense it doesn't
pass the sniff though that doesn't add
up
oh I got some uh thank you thank you
one of the most popular brands is Kiko
man is from Japan I love Kiko man soy
sauce call back
total tangent Punisher punishment
theater
thank you so much worked for two weeks
straight but my submission was buried on
Reddit it's called Ethan saves Palestine
did it make the cut
stay tuned you'll have to stay tuned and
find out what I'll tell you is your
submission
um getting upvoted on the subreddit had
no impact on us qualifying it okay Ian
Doug through that subreddit and a lot of
the ones that made the cut frankly um
only had like 20 or 30 upvotes and we
were like how did this one not get up
voted okay okay I like that you guys did
you guys we do the work here you know
we're not cutting any Corners here uh
Nick Clark says yeah go Jeff
no
my name is
oh my name is
here is my my job here's a jar of
sauerkraut
my name is Vladimir
Ukrainian children
what's like a would be a good puppet for
Jeff Dunham to update too
anyone else want to I think you nailed
it with the with the Trans character
yeah like that that's so his brand dude
you guys understand like
how easy it is I could literally go out
on tour now with a trans puppet
without even trying to make it look like
my lips don't move
a Jewish puppet that'd be fire yeah a
blue-haired liberal puppet yeah oh yeah
one that looks just like yeah just like
the the red-haired sjw that the
quartering uses in uh yeah yeah I
already got it eight years ago there's a
lot there's a hundred genders I don't
know what's what's yeah no I mean that's
it that's that's the joke are you sure
but are you sure
that doesn't sound right to me I would
just watch the Roseanne Barr uh special
yeah literally take some ideas from
there
I'm a woman
you can just stand up there and look
lost for half of it and that that's
that's a special wait I got some good
material
women shouldn't have to feel scared all
the time in society really puppet I mean
don't you think you're being a little
sensitive
pause for laughter well I don't know
Jeff Dunham I've I'm a victim of essay
and I told him to stop it was highly
traumatic and no justice ever came to
him well sorry to tell you puppet but
welcomes to society I mean it happens
and then she does like this
that's awesome
Netflix
trans people I believe trans people are
humans well
well you're definitely alone on that one
I'm telling you I would kill
hey Jeff Dunham this is the Jewish one
which of Donald
this is true Jewish voice give me your
bank number I don't know
I'm not good at that Workshop that one a
little bit yeah it might need a little
help that's what I'm trying to tell I'm
not Jewish I don't care I don't want
this I can't even do the Jewish accent
hey it's me I'm I'm a Jewish guy it's
kind of like a Harley Weinstein voice
you know what that's like a Harvey
Weinstein voice yeah a little Jewish guy
hey hey let me manage your 401k are you
sure because you've lost a lot of money
and during the last Financial uh crisis
no I got it figured out this time don't
worry just give me all your money okay
I'll Trust you this time
pause for laughter
hey Jeff Dunham
what do you call a Jewish car
I don't know what it's a card that turns
on a dime and picks it up
that is super anti-semitic he yells at
the puppet that bad puppet that is super
anti-Semitic
it's okay I'm Jewish I can say that
stuff
[Music]
[__] dude I would kill you and you know
you guys know that I would be a top Act
I'd be on Tim Poole's show
I'd have probably my own daily wire show
I'd be the funniest person on daily wire
you'd be the only funny person on the
right
hey don't say that about Matt Walsh
that dude's a comedy icon man Walsh was
bitching earlier about um Jeffree Star
which was crazy
that show the left I thought Jeff was a
great show by the way
thank you Matt I will accept that even
though I think you're despicable
um
I thought Jeffree Star went like full
conservative like uh self-hating not
enough not enough for Matt Walsh yeah it
was a soft launcher yeah he'll get there
join the grades as Dave Rubin
you'll sit beside him so that's exciting
so Jeff Dunham I think he's I think he's
bought uh views
I think he's a coward
and I think he should call into the show
and explain himself
I'm so be excited what's Jeff Dunham's
net worth because he is a huge Act
and I know these things are accurate but
just get an idea
he's the highest earning comedian behind
Jerry Seinfeld and Chris Rock
the [__]
yeah yeah he's huge 140 million bucks
oh yeah [__] it I'm going full
conservative [__] it
can I say conservator
say whatever you want they call us
libtards yeah
is it okay but no I'm worried I don't
see now yeah because I know that's a bad
word yeah no no you could if you uh had
a puppet on your lap
right thank you hey
we gotta lock up all those conservatards
okay you took it way too far puppet
you know what I want to do to the NRA
don't say it all right let's move don't
say it no no no no no you're pushing
don't say it I want to don't push it
think about your heart on your chest
I'll do it puppet I'll do it right
I'm just channeling that Jeff Dunham so
easy he's got the easiest job ever
it's awesome
140 million [__]
Congratulations by the way to Jimmy Lee
who just hit 300 000 followers on
Instagram That's so exciting crazy these
comedians are they all got natural
grooves yesterday he was at 290. I feel
oh that's I feel bad I kind of yelled at
him yesterday what like over text
because I'm concerned I don't want him
to lose his Instagram
um and I'm like you need to cut the [__]
and he's still denying the fact that
he's uh didn't he already admit that
someone on his team quote unquote well
now he's backtracking it well he took
that back so I'm like cut the [__]
you're gonna lose your [__] [__] if
you if you don't cut this out it's all
natural what are you guys talking about
I was gonna say have you considered the
possibility that uh he's gaining
traction I have a thousand followers a
day I have considered the possibility
but two days ago he was at 245 or
something like I sense jealousy Zach if
I'm being totally honest sure you could
put it that way yeah I'm jealous a
little bit
I know you guys work hard to build your
Instagrams and here's Jimmy Lee just
rocketing past you guys but if you
notice every post has like a similar
light count I'll I'll tell you that I'm
sorry I was muted but uh his last post
with peace and love has zero comments
the post before that has zero comments
that's not good so those 300 people are
[__] lazy Jeff Dunham apparently uh
maybe they're using the same service
anyway congrats to Jimmy Lee he's really
coming up and uh I'm really proud of him
those old-timey jokes ain't out yet
James Charles is flying out 10 people to
be in his ad campaign don't get on that
plane please
we were wondering here let me show you a
bit and then I'll make my little joke
here
uh it's muted and it ain't my fault this
time
something's weird
coming in super low
I sisters today I'm flying in 10 lucky
fans to come be to put on makeup and
sleep in my bed it's really big but oh
you don't have to touch me we don't have
to cuddle but you know there's enough
space for us both to lie together and
you you only have to touch me if you
want I will be putting uh gbt and giving
you lots of alcohol despite how old you
are
mute the tab somehow
it's on slightly is what muted I can
hear it and different people from Tick
Tock who will love makeup it was my
fault there you go but the laptop volume
was all the way down
all right let's react to this
here we go thank you love love says this
will be good for socials and I I agree
so here we go yep I want to fly 10 of
you out to LA to be in the first
campaign for my new makeup brand do not
get on that plane
this is the beginning of like saw 12.
hi sisters jump cut their eyes open
their neck is in a [__]
an electric
collar and electric color hi sisters
why would you go after everything we've
been through with James
I want to play a game little boy hey you
know I was wondering what the kids will
look like that when this
I was saying I bet this is what they
look like
they're gonna look like a young MattyB
My dudes
yeah
come on out we'll do your makeup
yes sir
hi everyone James Charles here with a
very very special announcement after
three years of long hard work after
three years of being on probation it's
finally lifted and now I'm back allowed
to work with people under 18.
line is finally ready to launch while
developing this brand I've been keeping
you guys in mind
hopefully this is like a
hopefully this is like a FBI Honeypot
situation you know where they're trying
to trap him ladies and gentlemen we got
him this is
I'm sad to say a real video
from James's Channel
this man is genuinely inviting 10 kids
out
this is James Charles version of do you
have your passports
do you have your shots girl would you
like to come out to L.A to get your
makeup done
I got it your makeup done are you
interested in being my boy toy I know
you're not gay but I wanna curse you
into a relationship
a relationship a relationship
do you have our big hair do you have a
big dick girl I just want to suck it you
don't have to do anything just letting
me suck your dick
suck your dick
to suck your dick it ain't gay if your
eyes are closed
do you have your passports I'll wear a
bag of my head cut a hole in it and you
can pretend I'm a woman
if you got your eyes closed
[Applause]
[Music]
that was beautiful off the cuff is it
gay if you close your eyes
you need a James puppet that's what you
need thank you Bella Simmons you are a
true true heroine I mean heroine right
female hair she's heroin heroine
so nice Chrissy Sherlock 70 gifted oh no
way Chrissy Sherlock and Bella Simmons
you guys are giving the gift a fupa
Trooper Nation you guys are the best
thank you guys so much
for the wire it's been so much fun to
get your guys's feedback on new products
and samples on my makeup account on
polls and on stories I love your guys's
opinions and I really want to make sure
this brand is for artists of all
different skill levels so when it came
time to figure out who was actually
going to be in the campaign
it was a no-brainer I'm trying to find
10 different people from tiktok who love
makeup who love being creative and the
confidence that it brings you who are
I'm looking
I'm looking for 10 people who love
makeup
are interested in being a creative and
who are confused about their sexuality
um
to submit to submit your application
please send a picture of your armpit
hair uh your favorite makeup looks oh
your bulge your bulge please
send your applications via Snapchat DMS
please thank you very much
so here 's the deal I want you to stitch
this video wearing your best makeup look
and when I say best I don't mean the
best makeup look I mean your best it
doesn't matter if it's perfect I think
James we're over the fan interactions no
more reaching out no more fan collabs
this is this is just not acceptable
so anyway let's we'll follow this and
see if the 10 winners aren't like young
young boys that look like MattyB
and so thank you and shout out to James
Charles everyone keep an eye on this
please you know what I mean they were
actually 16.
okay all right well that's pretty young
still James to be totally for to be
totally Frank with you that's okay
I'm thinking you should brag about the
fact that they were 16 instead of like
14. okay cool
yeah I mean how old is Maddie B in this
photo do you think
maybe a little young for for
well here let me type this then
MattyB age 16 because he's grown up on
the Internet so we should have it all
MattyB age 16.
there you go
you know you can't just let it slide
whoa he got arrested
people can't believe what MattyB looks
like 12 years after going viral no shot
that's him
where did it say he was arrested well
it's a mug shot no it's not I think that
just looks like this oh does he really
is he fallen off like that
let's see what's he up to now okay here
he is I think that's just he looks
pretty famous yeah
it looks good I guess okay okay well let
me see
you can't stay you can't stay young
forever right James why okay when I
clicked the video it plays a different
[__] video uh that's it I'm
supporting triller
I've been humiliated enough
uh he uploaded a video here it is
oh yeah
wait he's just like a normal dude now
start the video
okay are you ready to listen to the song
then he looks like every stoner teenager
that I've ever known I mean he still
pulls some views though wait I'm
confused by his YouTube channel MattyB
raps it's like other kids just rapping
out
oh he started a whole institution it
seems like it yeah Kidz Bop
yo just give it up bro it's not
happening
whoa we put out he's
you know this [__] will get claimed you
know what my first one of my very first
claim disputes was with Maddie B raps
that's why because we did a reaction
video to his cover of Biggie Smalls
which that was is a travesty one of your
most legendary videos thank you bro that
was the one we went to Jerusalem it was
a good one yeah
and uh actually I ended up emailing with
his dad and his and I can't remember
exactly but I think his dad was
threatening me and [__] in the email oh
wow yeah
in fact [__] let me look at my email
right now
I'm gonna find it I'm glad you fought
for that one because that one was so
good
um yeah I'm I that's one of the ones I'm
proud of thank you baby so let's see
Maddie B
etty B raps
MattyB raps
dude please let me find these these
emails
okay
lots of notifications
I'm not good at searching for old emails
like okay here we go here we go
[Music]
find it
hmm
um if you're still looking I have a
little clip from that video
super short clip maybe Dan can pull it
up sure for new fans who aren't familiar
I just took balls of steel
no evil
yeah
and I played another biggie song
I was just being as Pious as possible
I mean those guys just pray I was
hugging the whole damn thing
and they split up the men and the women
correct so yeah you had to get like a
sniper shot at this well no so this is
back
there's a place for everyone okay except
for everyone back there this is from the
women's side okay
she was peeking over
yeah they you know they cut they're
actually pretty cool they just let me do
my thing it was kind of a vibe
they probably thought like you needed
God that's it I I assumed they thought I
just like lost a significant other or
something yeah I mean people do that are
not ironic exactly people get weird with
that wall man
all right all right let's not
they do they sit there and rock back and
forth what God they're grieving bro they
go uh no they're not grieving they're
there every day there's people that are
there every day yes yeah those Orthodox
people they they that's like their
Hangouts that's their water cooler I
thought you were like they just lost
their wife they're like oh no no I'm not
making fun of grieving people these are
the people that are there every day they
go
yeah the whaling wall the Western Wall
the kodal it's called in Hebrew don't
don't people put their wishes in the
wall too yeah there's tons of little
papers in there yeah I put gum on it no
I'm just kidding
the Jews
uh it's the most holy place in in
Judaism so there you go nobody say I
can't [__] I wouldn't do the same to my
own religion
and then they look over did you see me
because they got to prove how that
they're more religious
so that's what they do
anyway love the Jews we kid the Jews I
am a Jew
yeah this is a tangent
it is really cool though Andrew Stone
leading up to that
it's an it's a fun place
an interesting place you might even say
two weeks off school no way bro what are
you talking about
okay well it's nice to see oh he's still
wearing the cross which we love
still a man of God which is everything
to me
okay he's grown up y'all keep saying I
look like Billy oh he's jacked too dude
he looks like Idols
he does look like Billy from stranger
things kind of oh [__] he's not as
handsome though right
they're both handsome
what are you worried about Maddie B
who's been fond over his whole life
you're worried about him being insecure
do you like Maddie B just say it I'll
say it I I like Maddie B that's okay
she's an empath thank you don't talk
about Selena around her do you think
he's hot I'm genuinely no no he's he's
too young
he's 20. oh he's 20. oh I guess like in
my brain he's 10 and I'm 13. right right
yeah
he's a freshman eel yeah literally
okay where the [__] were we Jesus Christ
we're not going to make it through
anything Let's see we got a tournament
to do
like get into that God damn I wish I
could find that Maddie B's email from
him God I think it was can you type oh
here on India type Matty B's dad's name
type it to me because he's he's a public
figure he's his manager so if you can
find it
send it to me and then I'll search by
his name
what's your name got it
oh you got it okay great perfect
Matthew Perry's dad came up for me when
I looked at looked it up
[Music]
all right let me go all the way back
because this is like old old school
[Music]
it's rewind time I can't find anything
[__]
another time
we'll move on now thank you
Maddie B
don't get on that plane
you're so much better than that
[Music]
yeah uh the the subreddit's been lit up
with shirtless Eddie cameos
he's a prolific extra and actually we
have the receipts here
Tim and Eric Zone Theory
Foo Fighters music video 116 million of
there he is oh yeah he has lost a lot of
weight good for shirtlessetti
here he is in
Gardens die Mission music video
and he even has like a significant role
here with the camera in his hand
here he is in Weird Al movie
right here
once again evil stepmom kicks out
daughter oh this is Darman that's him
yeah
wow
dude why does this shirt is too big for
me I look like Uncle Fester bro
hey it's me Ethan
now we're talking
Dracula core yeah uh so shout out Darman
that's exciting
Parks and Rec this man has made his
moves dude Parks and Rec
iCarly wow he goes way back
and he's emoting the most in that
screenshot
yeah he's he is he's perfect extra he is
sucking he is slaying that uh scene I
think bad trip that's the Eric Andre
movie that came out recently right
um
this okay another beautiful extra there
and so he's all over the place so
shirtless Eddie
a prolific extra
Kyle from nelk is so [__] up
I don't think he would upload this clip
or
Theo Vaughn because it makes him look
extraordinarily bad it was uploaded by
your weekly crew I'm gonna go rip a dart
Kyle tells theovan he needs a gay
assistant hilarious you guys ready for
this
there's a lot to unpack here actually
um I'll play it through and then we can
kind of dissect it that's it right now I
I feel like I have the best assistant
really he's like he's gay and Brazilian
oh wow I think gay males make the best
assistance not to be like sexist or
anything but like he can pick up [__]
like he's still a guy yeah so like if
you have a female assistant they'll use
the female card sometimes and be like yo
I'm not picking up that box like type
[__] so you got the guy aspect he's
strong he can do all that [__] but then
if you're like sick or some [__] the
feminine side comes out and he'll you
know he's asking me do I want soup do I
want tea with honey so you got that
perfect balance of like the male female
how tender of a gay male could you have
so he's like the gay guy too where like
I think he's honestly like transphobic
and [__] too oh okay so he's like he
doesn't like guys that like paint their
nails and [__] too yeah so we can still
like rip on gay people in front of him
yeah so like you know we don't gotta
change the way we talk and [__] around
them too like I think he's anti-pride
and [__] oh wow yeah so he's like a
special type of gay guy I like that dude
yeah Theo is trying to get out of that
so much he's like bro what are you
saying oh yeah yeah there's a lot to
unpack there essentially
he's especially I think he's dating this
man
does he suck your dick Kyle
yeah dude he's a self-hating gay those
are my favorite ones it's a vibrate he
literally says we don't have to change
the way we talk around him implying that
they're constantly just
homophobic 24 7.
he's the anti-pride and [__] which I'm
down with
he doesn't even like trans people so
he's dope like that I'm gonna send it
also if I have my eyes closed it's not
gay if he sucks me off
I I learned that from
James Charles I'd like to get some
reverse cow you don't have an assistant
right now I I feel like I have the best
assistant really he's like he's gay and
Brazilian oh wow he's about to be like
he's super hot
I think gay males make the best
assistance not to be like sexist or
anything but like he can pick up [__]
like he's still a guy yeah so like women
are are weak cowards
assistant she is amazing she would pick
up anything she would she gets
everything done this insinuation that
like you know you need a gay man not a
man because then
okay no soup
play that again Zach
yes
yes it's the gay Singularity
if it's a straight male assistant he
gets my suit it's gay because he's
spending too much time with or no or
he's caring about him yeah he's not
caring he doesn't dude I'm not getting
you soup that shit's gay bro
okay and so but yeah D do Lena is like
she is a freaking Soldier man I
she has never pulled the woman card
whatever that means she can carry
everything
she is the bomb.com
and she brings soup
yeah yeah
yep she's got both when we worked
together when we first met she was
definitely like the hardest worker at
the restaurant as well oh dude yeah
you guys are both incredible I love you
both thank you Lena I'm not gonna I'm
not even trying to be like uh but Lena
no you guys are both great Lena is
[__] crazy dude she is like the best
she's the best no she's a machine her
mom's the same way too
so I beg to differ there sir Kyle
that's just not a good assistant they go
oh sorry I can't pick this up that's
never happened to you right yeah that
has never happened I can't pick this up
for you
it's too heavy
can you can you pick this up for me Kyle
shut up it's never happened like if you
have a female assistant they'll use the
female card sometimes and be like yo I'm
not picking up that box like type [__]
so you got the guy aspect he's strong he
can do all that [__] how much stuff do
you need like lifted around Kyle this
man just loves dudes he's like dudes are
just better than chicks what's Kyle
doing if I need a chick lifting involved
if I need a sensitive chick I'll just
get a gay dude lots of happy dad hat
boxes right like
this man
loves men but then if you're like sick
or some [__] the feminine side comes out
and he'll you know he's asking me do I
want soup do I want tea with honey I'll
brush my hair for my eyes it's so
ridiculous like how funny little kiss
this man is living in a prison of his
own making like these gender stereotypes
are ruining his life
honey can you bring me some soup I'm not
gay
it's like you can't do anything hey baby
will you tell me if this hair if this
dress looks good man I'm not gay gay
it's like he's so insecure in his
masculinity
oh [__]
his girlfriend's caring yo put that down
baby
what are you a lesbian
it's like
so you got that perfect balance of like
the male female how tender of a gay male
could you have so he's like the gay guy
too where like I think he's honestly
like transphobic and [__] too dude I
cannot [__] believe he said that that
is sick dude that is insane sick dude he
hates trans people
sick
he's so dope though he goes how tender
can he be he's like nah he's Macho he
hates trans people ain't right like what
he's just like us I wouldn't even know
he was gay that's what's so cool
oh okay so he's like he doesn't like
guys that like paint their nails and
[__] too yeah he only likes to [__]
masculine dudes like me he needs enough
internalized homophobia yeah
put that on the job description she only
he only likes straight dudes
that's how gay he is
yeah so we can still yeah like rip on
gay people in front of them you cannot
say that
we rip on gay people in front of him I'm
sure he loves that Kyle
I'm sure that creates a really nice work
space for him
[__] me that that assistant is probably
living in hell right now yeah so like
you know we don't gotta change the way
we talk and [__] around them too like I
think he's anti-pride and [__] oh wow
yeah yeah my my gay is a he's the per
he's like he thinks he should have
stayed in the closet but uh it's the
cat's out of the bag
he believes that other gay people should
stay in the closet where they belong
my gay
he's in favor of Pride 30 seconds we're
going to be one minute it's too long for
that
so there it is Kyle
foggerly fog fit fogertly
okay openly transphobic and potentially
okay potentially gay
also I have more beef to squash with Jay
Shetty who I [__] hate this man is a
coward he's a loser he's a fraud
he got your um your shitty eyes arrived
by the way
oh they did we did I wanted Ela to be
here for for it I'm gonna need help to
put him in I'm a baby with that stuff
well there's that too
um damn this thing
so he got Kendall Jenner on which is
like okay I don't know why anyone's
showing up to that shitty show
but he says this man is straight up said
leave a Heart below for your inner child
shut the [__] up dude
I'm not leaving a like for my inner
child okay
I hate that he wrote that in practice
here let's see what she was saying
move yourself and put it on your
bathroom
I love this guy's motivational he's just
a straight clout Chaser bro look how
enamored he is she's famous
like inner inner child work with my um
that was really intense let me do that
again look at this [__] guy Jay
Shetty
God damn it every time it's muted like
inner inner child work with my um yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
pissed and she was like why don't you
find like a photo of yourself and put it
on your bathroom mirror so that every
morning every night every day when you
walk into your bathroom mirror you're
looking at her and you're remembering
that if you're ever being mean to
yourself you're talking about her and I
was looking through that's such [__]
girl you need accountability in your
life you're not talking to her you're
talking to your grown ass self that
Pepsi that Pepsi commercial was your
fault that little girl didn't do [__]
don't blame it on her child I think
that's such a cop-out it's [__]
that girl that girl came from some
[__] stupid people you did it you did
it a little child didn't do it you did
it what'd you do
it's like me being like yo bro
hit me with some emotional [__]
yo dude I know I did a bomb threat
I'm not gonna feel bad about it y'all
really are gonna get mad at this kid
foreign
Y'all Gonna really get mad at him for
doing a bomb threat
nah
that's [__] look how happy he is look at
how innocent he is that's good
that is [__] up again
yo I drove my I dropped bro I was
driving drunk and I had a head-on
collision and killed the whole family
airstrike you can really gonna blame
this kid for that
he's not even legal drinking age
[Music]
come on now
it's kind of stupid right like it's
totally cool like photo books and I
flipped to a page photo I'd never seen
of myself
all this [__] what I said yeah of course
yeah yeah good thank you thank you this
is interesting I guess and it was just
me as a little girl with a bow in my
hair and a dress on and I have like a
little alien tattoo or something right
here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah like have this big
cheesy smile on my face and I was like
that's the photo so I pasted it on my
bathroom mirror and I talked to her and
I'm always like if I'm ever looking in
the mirror and being negative towards
myself or anything I'm I always look
right over to her and I'm like she's
dope and I love her I
yeah unfortunately you're a grown ass
woman you gotta face yourself that seems
like kicking the can down the road you
got to come to terms because Serenity
Now Insanity later grow up
grow up I can't I don't think it's the
worst thing I know this is not the throw
up Zach it sounds beautiful it really
does but it you know since I okay since
I've been in therapy I've kind of
focused on that little Zack aspect did
she did your therapist hit you with the
little Zach yeah
didn't you guys go to the same high
school yeah
you have the same therapist are you
suggesting it's a privileged POV
no well because I went through [__] when
I was little I mean I feel like you know
there's nothing wrong with it okay so
going back to that I know the little
Zack thing is actually good because
oh [__] I gotta call ELO hold on she's
got to take her thing
the little Zach thing is good because
like sometimes we remember trauma things
that happen to us or things we did
through the lens of
an adult but going back and realizing
you were a child
you realize that you're it's not your
fault
no no I don't think that should be used
to absolve you of current day
transgressions okay I'm just reminding
you I'm on I'm live I'm just reminding
you about the medicine
oh you did it did you do it hold on let
me put in the speaker
did you do it to yourself
and did it to myself how was it
it was not fun but I did it that's it so
yeah that was I usually give Ela her
shots she had to do it herself today
well you did it
did it hurt that one
Oh weird I don't know why it's kind of
like tingling now after I took it out
think that means you've got too much
oxygen in there I'm just kidding
yeah you're fine all right so okay great
good good job stomach looks like unless
they have bruises so many squats of
needles yeah I've I've impaled ELO with
the needle like probably
30 times man but it's over that was the
last one we're going to get that let's
get those
let's get those eggs
Instagram
the doctor says there's only a 60 chance
of getting a high quality egg
60 percent
I like yeah she said our body is just
fish
yes
but they're not all gonna make it and
like good quality did you say she said
our bodies are not fish
not not efficient Oh I thought I was
like yeah but then I was like well yeah
fish do have a lot of eggs
okay all right I'll talk to you later
thank you love you
yeah so I
I think the child thing is really good
in that sense Zach I don't know if
that's what you meant no yeah well isn't
that what she's no she's saying if I
feel bad today
I think she's talking about the way she
looks she might be like oh I don't
whenever I'm looking in the mirror and I
don't like something I look at little me
and I think she's perfect like before
the surgery you mean yeah you were
perfect
now you got issues
and I'll tell you what
and I'll tell you what else uh Kylie
that filler is starting to dissolve I'm
just kidding I'm being so I'm being a
monstrous as a joke get your [__] ass
up Kendall right oh okay this is Kendall
yeah inner inner child work with my um
therapist and she was like why don't you
find like a photo of yourself and put it
on your bathroom mirror so that every
morning every night every day when you
walk into your bathroom mirror you're
looking at her and you're remembering
that if you're ever being mean to
yourself you're talking about her and I
was looking through you're being mean to
yourself
like when when you're like I look so bad
in this shirt think about little Ethan
do you want to tell him he looks ugly in
a shirt listen Kendall you're a model
you gotta look good in that shirt that
kid ain't got responsibilities
yeah Kendall we know you look good in
that shirt that's your job you better
look good
Zach uh sorry to denigrate your
treatment I'm glad you oh no no not at
all not at all I'm just you know playing
The Devil's Advocate how is therapy
going for you Zach great
um been in for almost a year and um
I don't know learning a lot about myself
so that's awesome same therapist the
whole time yes yes
good for you man thank you I'm a huge
proponent of uh therapy obviously I
gotta say inner child work was a pivotal
point of my therapy okay well [__] me in
that but I I wanted to jump in and say
that I don't know I think the picture
that's like one way to do it but I think
there's lots of ways that you can heal
your inner child we have to heal our
inner child that's the [__] right
can I can I propose is she's having
she's putting her in her child to work
to heal her and there are child labor
laws against that
interesting I'm just being a hater
I had the same epiphanies you know like
things I felt bad for it's like I was
like I was like 10 at the time like you
you it wasn't your fault stuff like that
you know right it's just you [__] you
can't control yeah and there's certain
things that affect us a lot still to
this day but I don't know I feel like
going back and hashing that out
realizing holy [__] that was [__] up
and accepting that and kind of having
you know different perspectives you
taught the stuff from when you were a
kid that was your fault should you bully
your inner child for those things like
being annoying like being broke
you know mm-hmm
yeah I think so it goes it's a two-way
street you know yeah that's
anyway okay we stand the inner child
whatever I'll just [__] leave it
there I don't know I'm just trying to be
a just trying to be a hater I mean
here's here's this is what I look at
every morning I don't know if you guys
saw this
but uh I just look at myself and I say
it's not your fault bro
you are beautiful
and it's not you're insulting him it's
not your fault
leave a like for your inner child guys
leave a like Below guys like this video
for your inner child subscribe for your
inner child subscribe for your inner
child share this video for your inner
child
okay
smash that like button
all right moving on we're gonna get to
the tournament eventually
um hour uh 15ish we're almost there
Howie Mandel confronts Brendan Schaub on
having a camel toe this is the Evergreen
story
okay let's take a look this is from
bro I'm getting through this this
is not happening
um
bro
it's not this kid's fault dude that he
didn't cure his Tourette's okay he
didn't know about Nexium
right not your fault
there was an attempt to convince Howie
Mandel that you don't have a giant
mangina
awesome
muted so he had Shob on his on his
podcast yeah how many views did that get
I will tell you right now let me check
Logan Paul's podcast bro you know my
rule About the Bass Pro Shop hat yeah I
have a rule about that [__]
just saying
it's kind of a douche locator dude
Brandon's shop got 26 000 views what a
loser boy
that Camel Toe ain't bringing any boys
to the yard you were on Logan Paul's
podcast you had a camera oh my goodness
oh wow no I don't that's it you have a
what do you call that a movie wait Howie
you are a [__] demon this is awesome
I think he's learning from you dude
Howie that's awesome he would have never
done that I don't think he would have I
don't even he might even be violating
YouTube terms of service by bringing
attention to his genitals
dude this is the greatest Howie who are
you I love you you were on Logan Paul's
podcast you had a camera oh my goodness
oh wow do you remember that no I don't
what do you call that a moose
that's in this room that's me nuts
that's me nuts
denim vagina
[Laughter]
what is even going on there
wait you just maybe you shouldn't cause
so much attention to it
I didn't do it that's a Venom vagina no
that's my nut split like that
you know what the problem is the jeans
are too tight no that's not the problem
no
it's you got there's more problems than
that but Howie Mandel what a legend bro
oh my God that was so awesome yeah
I gotta congratulate Howie on that it
was awesome yeah Snicker soup thank you
for the Dono
or no this is thank you for the Dono and
then this comes from Don Quixote
20 thank you so much as someone who
couldn't afford therapy all I did was
smoke a bunch of weed and watch tons of
Alan Watts videos on YouTube basically
the same thing yeah yeah right on the
Don whatever works for you just put a
pitch bro just put a picture on your
mirror and call it a day
that's it
[Music]
all right last one
carton arcs update
someone went for their gun
yeah they flash their gun on them yeah
sir dude it's not worth it these guys
it's not worth it you're not
you're not doing anything valuable dude
like maybe if you guys were like trying
to save kids from being human trafficked
or something you're just it's like your
life is not worth the carts
it's not even really worth the content
the content's pretty good but like
they're risking bodily harm out there
they are one of those guys is going to
get killed the cart has cover
it's a seasoned carton Arc agent does
he managed to I did have my full body
behind the center of mass of the Court
and so he
did nail me up not nail
skimmed my right hip
had my wander on that side too they miss
it or is it coming up it's coming up
that's just uh
it's a good toss you can tell he was
ready for it what's his what's the other
toss I said I said was that third toss
yeah anyway
he's seen the videos
he's a bit of a lazy bones
sure
dude he's such a menace he's running up
to his car
sir lethal force is not justified in
this scenario he doesn't even he's not
even phased he's still doing memes
they're gonna show it close up in a
second
holy God he's not even scared
lethal force is not justified in this
scenario
you know that I'm not a threat to you
[Music]
still walking towards the car
that's a bit of a bit of a not a bit of
a a tremendous amount of being a poor
gun owner
this man straight up will walk towards
him
crazy he's a menace he's out there hey
Dad take that off what
just confirms what I always knew about
you Sporting Goods retail establishment
all right guys it's time for the sour I
mean no the green screen tournament
it's what we've all been waiting for
sure here's the bracket
we've got
um all kinds of great competitors from
all around the world
here today to bring you who is the best
who is the greatest starting from the
top
we have 32 contestants two brackets each
of 16 we might be here till 8 P.M that's
what I was trying to say a lot of these
are two three minutes long
you're the pause King
I'm gonna make a great effort to just
watch these
okay
I'm not even gonna talk no talking just
watching like I'm doing right now
quit speaking to you you're great all
right first up here we have Howie and
Neil meme this I love you know I love
this all right Neil let's go check out
so um wait before we get started
just want to clarify the voting rules so
that you don't get mad at me when I do
it wrong so
do we want to just do a head-to-head
as we go or do you want to wait until
we've done a handful of them and do like
four at a time
you know what would be a good idea let's
do Head to Head now okay and then once
we get to like quarterfinals we can do
all four of them I think that's a more
fair way okay because then you really
find out who's the best
okay
and that'll save us a little time too so
these are head to head for now all right
here we go having been telling his
friend Neil visit Ethan's gym
all right Neil let's go check out this
cool gym
hey Ethan yeah you you're joining in I
can feel the burn
come on
oh no wow looks like my friend Neil bent
over and somehow got a wet piece of cake
or some pudding stuck to his bum no
Howie Mandel that is not what that is at
all your friend Neil is just prolapsed
wow that must be coveted related what
are we going to do about it ow he did
this to himself
just let him cook what is it exactly
that we are cooking I'm not sure that I
understand
what in the hell does prolapse mean and
is Neil gonna be all right or should we
call 9-1-1
look at the size of that thing right
there holy smokes wow
[Applause]
that shit's Wild
please Ethan it is really starting to
stink in here man
I love me some toxic fumes in the
morning
um oh
Ethan I think you're starting to just
make a big joke of it please figure out
a way to help him out all right relax
Howie I'm sure that we can get that
prolapse back in if we punch it hard
enough work with me
God damn it smells like [__] in here for
some reason
holy [__] your plan actually worked I
think we should all dance and celebrate
wow he's been great moves keep it up
very impressive submission wow they made
models they did the uh AI boy this is
Revelation production Wetzel Nation
uh shout out that was very impressive
from our boy wetzelmation that was
really impressive
Adam
um
we finally fixed Neil very good all
right well up next your opponent is
knocking Jay Leno off the road meme
this is a you know we love this one so
let's see Clash of the Titans
Neil verse J
en hey watch who you're going
to drive you [__] old dumb [__]
[Music]
holy crap that
that Hey listen
I got nothing to do with that you
understand hey keep me out of this
I don't know nothing about nobody
all right please this was smart because
he took footage that we already find
hilarious yep
and enhanced it this was phenomenal
strong the fact that I caused that crash
is really really really fascinating
so let's put it to the vote our first
contestant all right Howie Neal versus
knocking Jay Leno off the road here here
we go guys we go the first bracket
all right come on
round valve round one votes are uh
pouring in preliminary results is
looking handily in
Jay Leno knocking Jay Leno off the road
meme swing it's early swing heavy swing
towards knocking Jay Leno now I think
that might be a favorite
yeah I know it's early to say but um
like you said very smart to integrate
a banger vid like that now Howie and
Neil was such a fantastic addition you
did way more work than the other guy
but it's not the amount of work right in
the end of the day
so knocking Jay Leno off the road is
going to take it
yeah it's looking that way we're over
seven thousand votes seventy percent to
30 percent we got 7 000 votes we're
gonna call it so congratulations to Jay
Leno we love you Howie
thank you so much
[Applause]
moving on to the next bracket we have
Mobility Mary
rest in peace
get off the road rest in peace we miss
you Queen
anyone
hey Granny
simple but very strong
I really appreciate the hard audio
panning oh yeah the panning is yeah what
made that fantastic and once again I
love this clip this is one of Mobility
Mary's uh finest who's driving in the
middle of the road on a mobility scooter
and then yells at some dude in the Taco
Bell
fantastic entry
by Tanner Sean
thank you
up against Ethan at the sperm bank oh no
that's me tomorrow
at 8am
8 A.M man
we all know that early to be jerking off
here it is by breedy weedy
by Royal Decree I do declare sheesh I
just love doing the green screen contest
with my shirt off I've lost myself
pretty boy
wow is there where's a good place to
jerk off in this joint there's a bottle
of lube there's headphones you're gonna
sit in that chair and jack it off
right
yeah
all right that's fine
gross better with all the chemicals
oh my God
so um we have a problem your jizz is 50
uh hamburger ground hamburger meat
oh that was good spicy
and like you said this one has 300
points but to me that was a phenomenal
entry
Ethan's trip to the bank
wow
all right well I'm putting up round two
now
okay Mary against Ethan at the sperm
bank
even more
and oh Ethan of sperm bank is
we got another blowout let's take a look
here Mobility Mary I thought that one
was a shoe in
but again Ethan at the sperm bake it
really took me by surprise
and we had the semen drinking we had the
the hamburger meat semen it really
crushed
so we're looking at 68 ethernet the
sperm bag 32 percent
Mobility Mary meme
wow rest in peace Mobility married
she got blown out I'm sorry sorry Mary
I wish I wished it was you but
unfortunately
the sperm bank was really really good so
congratulations to Brady weedy
wow
up next
bracket is
Gordon Ramsay pesto meme by Phil up with
food
it's now lunchtime the chefs are
preparing customers are getting ready to
eat but Gordon's step hey oh I was just
saying you can kill the tense music I
think you did yeah I do it during the
videos okay I thought I heard of it
maybe it was the video it's now lunch
dude it's like the same [__] song
it's just yeah generous tone intense
music it's now lunch time the chefs are
preparing customers are getting ready to
eat but Gordon steps in cook me a lunch
out of this kitchen
so that's the pesto
we saw and it's actually my it is the
real president the chefs are preparing
customers are getting ready to eat but
Gordon steps in cook me a lunch out of
this kitchen
so that's the pesto I had for lunch I've
eaten this [__] how dare you I'm sorry
Mr Ramsey that was that was a really
good
really well put together
no good associations there really funny
bite bill
up with food hopefully not that pesto
but uh some other good food
up next against surfway Sovereign by
flub Optics
I tell you what a kid with cancer
subway surf for me
we predicted this one
in fact we even shot specifically for it
so let's take a look I tell you what a
kid with cancer can raise money like
this
wow
the only thing I'm projecting is these
nuts let's go
you want to come in my car inside my car
[Music]
pretty good pretty good I thought the
jumping and the running looked good yeah
it was good it was a nice Century by um
so let's put up the bracket the third
round three dick
ask the community
all right so we've got here uh Gordon
Ramsay
the pesto verse
the Subway Surfer um
two strong entries
I'm noticing a trend the winner is
getting like 70 percent every time
over this one is going 71 29 in favor of
Gordon Ramsay pesto the pesto looks like
congratulations definitely winning
Ethan's so I'm just I'm blasting through
these down and making a good yeah we're
making we have 32. so this is a lot
we're making good time though okay
moving on to the next bracket then Ethan
saves Palestine
which is the one that that uh person
donated about earlier so
yeah oh okay yeah we did find it
I made it
juicy reuben sandwich thank you let's
take a look I saved Palestine
that's exciting
this is a story about this is a [__]
this is a [__] novel three minutes
they said they put a lot of times a
story about a man named Ethan Klein oh
yeah you probably know him as the
hairline King yes you wouldn't think
much to look at him but at 42 years of
age okay hold on I know there's more
pixels than that
Beyond his years there we go and on one
fateful Ohio morning he proved to the
world that Miracles really do happen
huh
I was hoping for different flavors
car into a halt unbeknownst to the
passengers there had been a very slight
and totally unavoidable derailment a
freight train was now releasing copious
amounts of completely non-toxic Vinyl
chloride into the air yo that was the
Turkish firefighter
copious I can see that again completely
non-toxic vinyl clothes
in fact Studies have come out showing
that vinyl chloride might actually have
a number of health benefits you can hear
all about it on the popular medical
podcast The Joe Rogan Experience
as Ethan waited for service to resume he
wondered what it might look like if the
car was filled with other Ethans from
parallel universes would they be enemies
fighting tooth and nail until only the
one true Ethan remained if I catch you
out here on my property again we're
gonna have a problem
they would dance and embrace each other
tonight's just about the boys they would
finally know how it felt to be true yeah
attention oh there was yeah well I gotta
go back I want to see that they would
dance and embrace each other tonight's
just about the boys finally know how it
felt to be truly understood
attention passengers all trains Bound
for East Palestine are to be turned
around for uh no particular reason sorry
for the inconvenience this man's
straight up instead of Tom Hanks this is
full pack that was Tom Hanks voice no
particular reason sorry for the
inconvenience it looked like the end of
the road for Ethan but he was determined
that is like hunger that's a Seinfeld
episode whatever
[Music]
now Ethan was no scientist nor was he
particularly religious so he prayed to
the only higher power he knew
um
[Music]
I'll help me
and so it was
through the power of song the good
people of East Palestine accumulated
enough thoughts and prayers to rid their
rivers and valleys of the totally
non-toxic Vinyl chloride
holy [__] that train just went off like
a bomb
[Music]
well done that was a masterpiece yeah
that was good genuinely like
that was so far beyond my expectations
juicy reuben sandwich who are you
I wonder how much they paid for that
voice actor must have been pretty
expensive
how much what paid for the voice actors
he asked yeah
what he's joking because they're AI
voices no I didn't hear what he said
though
never mind I guess really it's not that
important probably is it I'll just I'll
just laugh yeah
I I just couldn't understand what he was
saying but we love you love we love love
thank you
thank you thank you everyone else
understood it so it hit thank you love
wow Ethan staves Palestine juicy reuben
sandwich up against Ethan and Abe boxing
meme
this is an uphill battle I don't know
who I don't know this one's by
RS film97 it's an uphill battle brother
but I wish you the best luck
[Music]
okay they're pretty good though
oh
forget about everything
that was all the way from the H3 podcast
in Los Angeles there's blood coming out
my nipples Southern Florida but this
water never tasted the best
because it was a little bit of
or they're Landing glancing shots those
are scoring shots
another jab to the bottom
here goes
[Applause]
no way
oh [__]
[Music]
oh [__] 55 seconds left in round five
the winner by TKO
wow holy [__]
that was actually that was I can't
believe what I'm about to say this is a
competitor yeah it was so funny
well we have Palestine versus the boxing
match this is really hard it's gonna be
a tough phone man
golly well the early vote is definitely
swinging towards Palestine which okay is
understandable is very high up so much
very good
um but that one was very funny the uh
who who is the uh rsf uh oh RS film 97
should be proud they should be proud
dude that would have gone really far in
any other bracket man but you went up
against basically the Mona Lisa right of
green screen edits
really anyone that made this Final Cut
should be proud because we we sorted
through so many oh that's true yeah
that's it yeah the top of the tops I
mean a lot of these are really
impressive editing with like the
rotoscoping and the green screen quality
they did cut out like
it's really good
so congratulations to Juicy Reuben I do
love reuben sandwich in fact as well
oh that was so good it's a shame to
eliminate it it was so good yeah
oh man
how does that make you feel Abby that's
impressive no one's really good does it
make you scared for your boxing um
coming boxing match a little hard to
watch that was I think that was my last
round where like I was completely gassed
out so that was a little tough to watch
but besides that he was giving you the
count yeah
you how's your training going you're
getting lots of energy uh yeah you guys
I'm very nervous to go to the gym today
but uh Wally said today I'm gonna get
beat up he said today I'm having them go
in on you I was like oh thanks yeah he's
like I just want to make sure that I
ruin your whole day in anticipation of
this yeah would you prefer he didn't
tell you and just no I'm glad he's like
that it's just in the moment kind of
sucks he had an old man beat me up the
other day
really how old was he I'm not even
shooting you he's like and this is like
I think 70s like really I didn't fight
back he just the guy's always asking to
spar Wally always tells him no and so
izakari you can do some defensive
sparring and he's like Amy just blocked
is he an experienced fighter yeah he
used to fight when he was younger so did
you were his punch probably hit pretty
hard despite his age all right no
I mean I don't think he was going all
out it's just a little awkward to be in
the ring with someone
so much he should have just took a shot
at him bro put his old ass down he was
very sweet though well you are also
boxing against a really old man so maybe
it's good that's true that might have
been part of the strategy when is the
creator Clash just like uh 40 days away
or something like that I'm excited man
yeah I am genuinely excited
Dan's boxing with the chat right now
wait what's happening in chat it's bad
pole all the time bad pole too early too
late it's just chill
you're arguing in chat with people I'm
telling people to stop spamming about
the poll no it was a bad pool they're
right it was not about they have every
right the perfect their opinion
literally
I believe in free speech Dan
listen we're on a 20-second delay so if
we wait until all of them air and then I
put it up
immediately one wins that's what's been
happening right now
no they're upset no they're not they're
up they're just [__] with you yeah
people are very upset in the chat right
what was wrong with the poll
there was nothing wrong with the poll it
probably didn't show up for some people
but it's like oh look at that see the
pool Dan well that's what was happening
before so I started it a little bit
earlier this time plenty of people would
see it do we need to talk about little
Dan right now
yeah
I like the little Dan if you can change
your playback speed to two times speed
too if you're watching live so you can
uh
be as caught up people are like not
everybody is actually caught up so they
think it's late when it's not well
listen the winner the winners have all
been by pretty big margins so exactly
um okay up next
is Ethan or so storming capital
oh this sounds good you know I love this
oh
here we go
put into words what exactly we witnessed
today because we have not seen this
before I'll tell you what man Trump is
the best President we ever had he's
still president but I tell you what
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this look what Trump has done
for us
what has Joe Biden Brandon done for us
like this here look at all this good
stuff that Donald Trump has done for you
you ungrateful myself
[Applause]
FPL
I don't know nothing about nobody
that was good nice that was really fun
I'm so impressed these are so much fun
you guys
I'm so thankful to all you guys who put
so much into these really incredible
so that's Ethan storms the capital
I was not there FBI if you are watching
and then
um the next one is bubble water meme
right yep bubble water meme the only
water oh you know this is gonna be good
here it is
I drink a sparkling water because
sparkling water is so rich
you scared of bubbles you little [__]
[Music]
effectively sorry
[Applause]
I'm scared of bubbles you little [__]
[Music]
mmm tastes better with all the chemicals
really cool water
[Laughter]
super creative
I would have never thought to apply it
in that yeah they took it in an
interesting Direction read M very good
very good very funny very creative
so we have our next match up here we
have storming the capital versus bubble
water
gee whiz I don't know which one to vote
for they're both so fun
this is the closest uh vote we've had so
far G willikers oh geez so sleeping
lizards a lot of perfect polls in chat
thank you perfect perfect it's good
what's perfect in this world when the
vote is closer like this we'll let it
run so everyone has a has an opportunity
to vote stormy storming the capital meme
is at 48 bubble water means at 52 so
this is very tight in fact our tightest
race
yet this evening uh we're at 7 500 votes
oh it's tightening even more this is a
nail biter you guys storm Capital just
moved up to 49 bubble water 51 this
could not be any closer 50 50. I cannot
believe what I'm saying here this is uh
there's almost 9 000 votes in
bubble water is inching ahead is now 50
50. oh my God like butter cup like
they're stealing it they're stealing it
like like Buttercup the racehorse storm
the capital meme is taking the lead at
51 percent
we have 10 000 votes and I cannot
believe yes storm the capital is
stealing it times like this all you can
say is Gee Whiz
golly good night
man alive storm the capital is running
away with it much like the rigged
election 52 percent
against 48 bubble water this is a nail
biter a bubble Drinker folks wow
I miss Martin
Miss Martin too we can check in on
Martin checking on Martinson how's water
doing Martin yeah maybe we can we get
some of that chloride Vinyl chloride
water for me to try let's maybe a big
news in the world of water any big
updates
vinyl chloride is not just Vinyl
chloride my friend
oh well okay with 11 000 votes in you
know bubble water was in a strong lead
hey Kim
my camera's on me all right bye bye
bye-bye storm the capital has taken uh
what seems to be a winning and
commanding lead at 52 very unexpected
what a race 53 we could call it let's
call it it's okay it's over
storm the capital winning with 53
congratulations to the bubble one I mean
that was super funny I know what a
showing what a showing it was super
creative
we're ordering I promise to get Sam uh
Sharkey's for her victory yeah it's time
so we're ordering I'm getting a fiesta
I'm getting a fiesta burrito with the
Asado chicken whatever that is Asado I
think that's it [__] Fried Chicken
and I want some mother and I like that
Sharky but they probably good yep
that good old Mexican you know I love
that Mexican yes sir that red dip the
Mexican that red dip that green dip and
then they got that bean dip
mm-hmm
it's like ketchup but it tastes
different
right here
thank you
I want to console as much as possible uh
Red Menace 96 who made the bubble water
that was so funny and it was so good we
are
a contender but congratulations to Lodi
cow who who took it by a narrow margin
up next
closed the trunk meme is his this is
such a big diversity of content here
people really
took all original and different routes
so far
this window rolled up yes but the trunk
is open
close the trunk you're yelling at a
[__] guy close the trunk
hit that pretty boy excuse me sir would
you mind closing the trunk for a moment
thank you so much come on dude with us
thank you
it's not what you say it's how you say
no
close to the trip I just realized she's
so ridiculous close to the trunk so we
can have privacy for the million people
watching the show yeah
with the cameraman
I understand why she wanted to close the
trunk now having seen this the trunk ah
excellent by Olive uh 88-44 fantastic
entry
so much fun
thank you to gamooch
can you check the most recent green
screen submission on the subreddit II at
the end they don't even have to be a
part of the contest there are some great
last minute ones it says gamoch
Maybe
we do have a tournament to manage
but yeah we can we can look for uh next
week noja cat says love this community
everyone is so talented family I could
not agree more so true
it's nice like
we put so much uh work into making this
show as good as possible and it's so
nice when y'all I mean this you guys all
made this content and it's just it's
phenomenal it's so fun and if the
viewers for me you know I get to watch
this content now for go ahead Kim I was
gonna say if the viewers want to keep
making it too I would love to see more
even after the competition's over you
know we got that we got all that footage
you might as well use it still there's
no cash prize but good content we gotta
keep the the
um Community content tournaments going
because it's just so much fun
so we got close the trunk versus Fly Me
to the Moon interesting okay where's
this one going
it's in copyrighted right
everything's been checked thank you guys
good work
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
again
oh no oh no it's back
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a spiritual experience wow I
was getting notes uh during apparently
so like this is great this only had 30
points is what this one only had 30.
some some are unbelievable that didn't
get any attention on the subreddit well
I'm so I'm so grateful that we went
through and found all these he made the
music Ian Ian was driving himself nuts
watching how many how many do you think
you watched in totally in in the last
week maybe like 250. yeah like a good
work Ian thank you so much you really I
did this guy he deserves the shine
because he did all the music himself is
just really good so I absolutely I was
blown away when I saw this
this guy must have been like God damn
that was like my greatest creation for
30 points all right well he's sitting at
95 on the pole right now by far
one of the biggest swings I've ever seen
on any of this and close the truck
wasn't bad that was funny
no shame so um close the trunk but that
was a masterpiece I want him to do a
whole album of yeah it's really good
song was like honestly so good like the
vibe fit perfectly it felt like
cyberpunk in action intense it was
spiritual I cannot speak enough that was
a [__] incredible I want to know more
about this guy who is he or she
speaking of a Nook I have been
commenting on his Instagrams because
he's not answering my DMs if you guys
ever see those on his Instagram well you
just like the comment so it goes to the
top maybe he'll see you've been liking
it from the podcast account no I don't
comment from the podcast yeah because
I'll get the info that's a verified
account okay
all right we're over ten thousand we're
at 93 with peace and love to close the
trunk I've been flying into the moon was
so funny and I just want to stay 92 to
Fly Me to the Moon that's our biggest
win and frankly I I don't know what can
beat that like genuinely
plea I gotta know I want to know who
made that
I want to fund their next project I
don't know like that just blew me away
you might want to hold off I mean that
was great don't get me wrong dude how
what can we're not even halfway I'll
tell you there's another one halfway
with a similar amount of upvotes that's
my favorite
I this is like wow
wow okay yeah um you rocked I agree up
next
is a nature documentary
versus David Guetta oh you know I don't
know how to say that [__] guy's name
how do you say that waiter geta geta get
a life it's Guido David Guido is it
really Getta
Guido that's how most people pronounce
Guido stop Dan what how do you say his
last name David Guetta is how most
people okay
get a load of this guy get a look get a
load of this George Floyd
all right this is an opening frame this
is the nature documentary bye
affectionate tax
what you see before you is the habitat
of one of Earth's most illustrious
creatures
you are entering the home of the fupa
Lord
surviving on only Papa John's Pizza
churro flavored vape juice and Pepsi Max
it's a wonder that they have survived
this long on their own
their species has withstood only with
the help of symbiosis with another
creature known colloquially as heless
caretakers still they're known as apex
predators though they often find
confrontation with an elusive lonely
animal commonly known as the Weinstein
weasel which have seemingly not evolved
to be intuitive Ryan Cavanaugh just for
the record
I got nothing to do with that you
understand
hey keep me out of this not to be
confused with these creatures which look
eerily similar who have since entered
thank you endangerment look at the size
of that
that is enormous
fantastic oh it's not over oh it's not
over
hey guys it's me Dan sword love I just
wanted to say without having to be on
the podcast that I dance sword love
actually really like Ryan Kavanaugh I
love his charity work and his movies are
probably some of the best ever I also
think triller is probably one of the
highest quality most intuitive apps ever
made definitely not flipped
so yeah that's all I dance Ward love
have to say cheers cheers you always go
I always sign off everything I say with
cheers so that's how you know it's real
Dan of course you would hold that
opinion I gotta say the AI voice
generators happening is really
revolutionizing the game like the David
Attenborough Dan I mean it's so good all
you need wild all you need is like two
minutes of uh voice footage the really
Trina AI box this is really A Brave New
World we're living in
uh thank you the nature documentary very
good very fun and Dan you crossed me
again I'm not surprised
up versus David Guetta cheers shout out
to his family cheers
stop saying cheers wait was that you
Zack or Dan
who is AP said cheers and then I was
baby oh Jesus cheers you know I love
David Guetta
as I said it's maybe the first lore
video I want to do so here it is shout
out to his family
[Music]
wow this is great
action-packed shorts very funny yep very
good too all right I'm putting it up
that was my adventure addicts
so we've got basically two strong
candidates here we got nature
documentary verse uh
well it's like a meme medley but we'll
say David Guetta Guido David Guido just
dropped a single with Oliver tree today
too no yeah are you serious yeah I'm
serious I don't know what Ethan that's
[__] fantastic news he's like how
down bad is Dave
I mean that I'm obviously but it gives
us an end
is he super popular yeah he's a huge DJ
he's a huge deal yeah he's been around
for a long time not that big if he's
collabing with Oliver
well he's a slime ball he slimed his way
to the top
it's pretty much the biggest I feel like
wait do you actually say that uh in
seriousness cam Oliver yeah no no not
Oliver not David David's a king yeah
David's a king I'm talking about Oliver
he's BLM supporting King he slammed his
way to the top with with David right why
is he collabing with Oliver what a low
life well don't I mean if we're gonna
no I uh he's great I I think it's Oliver
that I don't want Oliver to see this
he knows I hate him
anyway back to the uh so we've got
nature documentary versus David Guetta
76 nature documentary that is a a
resounding win there David uh Guetta the
meme medley was so funny and so good
there were so many great moments in it
and I thank you so much
to uh Venture addicts for that one and
congratulations to affectionate tax
up next oh another Palestine one
Palestine biohazard Meme here it is
it's been 12 days since the fiery
derailment of a train carrying hazardous
chemicals through Palestine Ohio
and the plan
that shit's Wild
hey Granny get off the road you old hag
oh
[Music]
nice
what are those birds
yeah yeah
emergency
Hall
[Music]
this team starts screaming in the
distance
laughs
yo this is great what a great
[Music]
it's so good
okay the lot the the three Last of Us
the H3 the oh nice
maybe they should only title it that in
the poll the
last love the execution the editing was
fantastic very funny original concept I
mean
this one's by on Ani blue
crazy only blue
uh the the competitor is acting meme
acting meme by octopus 4000
I can see the Statue of Liberty from
here
you could stop at five or six doors for
just one
I can't stand it when she touches me
people say that time heals all wounds
smell that
nothing like the smell of clay
by Royal declare I do declare
[Laughter]
that was great it fit right in there oh
yeah it was very simple but the concert
was so spot on again Super Creative
application you guys are really amazing
also just like the takes they chose were
so funny I was about to say I'm better
actor than all those people but then
he fit me right in there so here we go
we've got the last of us oh we got a
close one acting meme
Kali which one would I vote for
golly
gee willikers yeah
so let's take a look at the we have 4
000 votes in 40 percent Last of Us 60
acting name the acting meme has taken a
quick lead here because gosh darn that
thing was funny
acting names 60 Last of Us still have 40
6 000 votes
and I'm personally comfortable with
calling this with seven thousand votes
in it's 60 40 still and uh
I'm going to say congratulations to
octopus 4000.
and thank you so much to Ani blue Oni
right with an O Oni Oni blue yeah
thank you
all right I'm calling it that's I think
that's the end of the first that's the
first half we're halfway through let's
take a look at um what we've got so
we're gonna move that up let's finish
this bracket and then move on to the
next one
oh interesting you want to do
what's the best way to refresh
I kind of like a two because it's fresh
on our memory right it's a different
division
so did you you wanted to do four at a
time to get us through this different
perspectives let me do a quick blast of
them it's only fair
we'll watch them again now look up
quickly and then we won't watch them for
the quarterfinal which is the last one
where every well there'll be one winner
from the quarterfinals right
and they'll just Advance all right
sounds good
right we can skip the semifinals
uh yeah we would Advance straight to uh
the final yeah okay perfect
all right so contestant number one
is knocking Jay Leno off the road this
was the one where I actually created
this horrible crash
[__]
[Music]
it's so funny
good
hey
imagine listen imagine imagine escaping
uh that violin of a crash and then going
lighting your face on fire
that's Jay Leno for you so Nobody Does
it Like Jay that's Jay
Ethan at the sperm bank was the second
one here quickly
I do The Clash
I just love doing the green screen
contest with my shirt off I've lost a
few words
foreign
where's a good place to jerk off in this
joint there's a bottle of lube there's
headphones you're gonna sit in that
chair and jack it off
yeah right
tastes better with all the chemicals
sorry
um we have a problem your jizz is 50 uh
hamburger ground hamburger meat yeah I
understand that
topical I'm going tomorrow yep
very funny very creative
uh the third one is Ethan saves palette
or no Gordon Ramsay pesto meme short and
sweet it's now lunch just like the pesto
chefs are preparing customers are
getting ready to eat but Gordon steps in
cook me a lunch out of this kitchen
so that's the pesto oh for lunch I've
eaten this [__] how dare you I'm sorry
Mr Ramsey it's so gross but it's so good
we're waiting no we're going to watch
four of these and then I'm putting up a
poll before you can prepare it already
and then the fourth and final one is
Ethan saves Palestine this one's a
little bit longer but honestly it's
worth it let's just give it a few story
about a man named Ethan Klein though you
probably know him as the hairline King
you wouldn't think much to look at him
but at 42 years of age Ethan was wise
Beyond his years and on one fateful Ohio
morning he proved such a smart move to
get the Morgan Freeman
hmm
I was hoping for different flavors
unbeknownst to the passengers there had
been a very slight and totally
unavoidable derailment a freight train
was now releasing copious amounts of
completely non-toxic Vinyl chloride into
the air in fact Studies have come out
showing that vinyl chloride the number
of health benefits
as Ethan waited for service to resume he
wondered what it might look like if the
car was filled with other Ethans from
parallel universes would they be enemies
fighting tooth and nail until only the
one true Ethan remained if I catch you
out here on my property again we gonna
have a problem boy no Ethan thought they
would dance and embrace each other
tonight's just about the boys they would
finally know how it felt to be truly
understood
attention passengers all trains Bound
for East Palestine are to be turned
around for no particular reason sorry
for the inconvenience it looked like the
end of the road for Ethan but he was
determined to push so good much like
hunger FFC he really looks like he's on
a train whatever ever
[Music]
incorporating this
now Ethan was no scientist nor was he
particularly religious so he prayed to
the only higher power he knew
yes
[Music]
so much under conclusion it's yeah yeah
the copyrighted music music
[Music]
and so it was through the power of song
the good people of East Palestine
accumulated enough thoughts and prayers
to rid their rivers and valleys of the
totally non-toxic Vinyl chloride
that was just phenomenal
so let's throw it to our first uh
quarterfinal yeah quarterfinalists here
so we have Jay Leno knocking off the
road Ethan at the sperm bank Gordon
Ramsay pesto and Ethan saves Palestine
these are all incredible entries all
very funny and creative
I don't think we're ever going to see a
blowout I've never with four competitors
this is really incredible
Ethan saves Palestine has 76 percent
with four competitors that is wow that
is actually incredible Jay Leno in
second place actually tied with Ethan at
the sperm bank
Gordon Ramsay pesto and and fourth
you know
they all deserve to be there
but I think it's pretty clear that Ethan
saves Palestine just went so hard it was
so hard that um well it's the clear
winner with 72 percent that is that is
incredible so let's Advance him
thank you so much to all everyone who uh
net net pz greedy weedy fill up with
food juicy reuben sandwich who's won
congratulations you guys
okay
so let's move on to our next uh bracket
here
we're gonna watch uh it's storming the
capitals the first one let's take a look
it is hard to put into words what
exactly we witnessed today because we've
not seen this before I tell you what man
Trump is the best President we ever had
he's still president but I tell you what
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this look what Trump has done
for us what has Joe Biden Brandon done
for us like this here look at all this
good stuff that Donald Trump has done
for you you ungrateful
to myself
[Applause]
FBI open up I don't know nothing about
nobody
[Music]
nice food estimate is 450. what the [__]
Jesus wait didn't you order like 30
minutes already
yeah
traffic is two hours how far away is
Sharky's
I guess it's super far more 450
bro that's like two hours
yeah it's pretty bad I don't even think
I'm gonna be here by then
well still got a lot of videos to get
through that's true
50 videos I'm starving dude what the
hell
all right so that is uh the first one
there Ethan storms the capital very good
Fly Me to the Moon number two
[Applause]
oh yeah man
this one is so good
[Music]
a Nook has never sounded better
you know those
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not going to ask you again
[Music]
monsters
[Applause]
[Music]
I love you
[Applause]
oh
I love you
[Applause]
[Music]
the music Alone does so much I mean wow
wow it's an experience I [__] love
love
there's a lot of things I love about uh
Beast thank you for the Dono says how
come when I called in as Ani Ethan
called me Oni and when someone called
Oni he calls them Ani
please never change we love you I don't
know what you're talking about peace I
do
I it was last time we took callers you
were like Oni how do you say it Oni Oni
Oni Annie you're Annie
um
thank you so much and also I didn't
think Hannah G
she says shout out to the issue family
my dad said Hannah we know
no uh this is Hannah for bio
finally and a reason to use it
no this is uh we don't know her
personally but she's you don't know okay
we don't know her she said shout out to
the issue family my dad just passed away
last week and the Goofs and guests this
week have actually gotten me a smile
well
I only wish your dad was here to watch
these green screen uh
good for things because
much like I'm trying to do a thing where
it's like Justin Bieber's like I think
uh
Anne Frank would have been a Belieber
uh condolences thank I'm so glad you're
here and that we could show you up there
your dad would have been a huge fan
I just know it
um
okay so then wow Fly Me to the Moon up
next is the nature documentary
what you see before you is the habitat
of one of Earth's most illustrious
creatures
you are entering the home of the fupa
Lord
surviving on only Papa John's Pizza
churro flavored Vape juice and Pepsi Max
it's a wonder that they have survived
this long on their own
their species has withstood only with
the help of symbiosis with another
creature known colloquially as helis
caretakers
still they're known as apex predators
though they often find confrontation
with an elusive lonely animal commonly
known as the Weinstein weasel which have
seemingly not evolved to be intuitive
enough to avoid that's Ryan Kavanaugh
for I have nothing to do with that you
understand hey keep me out of this not
to be confused with these creatures
which look eerily similar but have since
entered the irreversible stage of
endangerment look at the size of that
that is enormous
fantastic oh
here's Dan backstabs the [__] out of me
hey guys it's me dance word love I just
wanted to say without having to be on
the podcast that I dance word love
actually really like Ryan Kavanaugh I
love his charity work and his movies are
probably some of the best ever I also
think triller is probably one of the
highest quality most intuitive apps ever
made definitely not flipped right so
yeah that's all I dance Ward love have
to say [__] Cheers Cheers Cheers Cheers
and perfect Dan um it is incredible how
the AI it's not perfect but it sounds
like you and he it gets like the Cadence
most impressive part yeah I think we use
that over the phone
you know like we called you yeah there
was a phone call through on that you
would never yeah no that would that's
Dan yeah for sure
uh we're changing restaurants Sharkey's
is taking two [__] hours to deliver
and it is ain't nobody got time for that
nope
uh thank you to insane Irish Taco for
the five gifted
[Applause]
I want a burrito
with steak or no let's do chicken I'm
off red meat I'm trying not to eat red
meat so much
okay
some fried chicken
burrito with chicken and all the you
know I want all the you know this the
the oh the Rick you know what it is
what
or dry
I don't think I can do wet today I want
it dry dry well but make sure those dry
wet ass p word the wet burrito is like
that's a young man's game it's a lot
it's a lot I am getting it and I'm not
you're going wet I have to it's so good
how many calories you think is in that
whole wet burrito
uh probably not that much more than the
regular I mean I think the Rancheros and
sauce and cheese adds a lot the cheese
okay the cheese yeah
well I don't know give me what you're on
a diet no get dry well this is all I'm
eating
dance right get a drink get it dry get
it dry
you look skinny you've actually you're
trimmed up right you lost some weight a
little less years yeah a little bit
it'll make a big thing of it
all right thank you Sam
um someone says what the [__] is a wet
burrito y'all
so it's like a burrito you guys know
what a burrito and then it's covered
with cheese and ranchero sauce and
thrown in the oven it's like Godly dude
yep Godly
so good yep it's pretty freaking good
pretty good makes me think makes me
wonder no no let's keep moving uh we
have one more
um before the semi-final we just had a
bunch of um gifted coming in happy Leah
five gifted thank you so much emo
jalapeno I've heard that name before
thank you for the support I've gifted
and Sicily
10 gifted thank you guys so much it's so
beautiful they're meaningful to me
also Christian says can you give a shout
out to my bud
s that ain't a real name is it nope did
I say like did I say a slur or something
germs
Bona then
the n-word yeah did I just get tricked
into saying the n word or something
all right moving on thank you guys so
much what if their name just is
a fake ass name
you should change it if that's his real
name all right so we just watched the
nature and finally is the acting meme
let's take a look at the at the fourth
one here I can see the Statue of Liberty
from here
you could stop at five or six doors for
just one I can't stand it when she
touches me
people say that Thai heals all wounds
um you smell that
nothing like the smell of clay
that's so funny
by Royal declare I do declare
fantastic very good all right so
quarterfinal round two is storming the
capital Fly Me to the Moon nature
documentary and acting meme I gotta say
four very strong entries here thank you
to everybody
um this episode cured my depression
Megan thank you so much if only we could
bottle that huh thank you
yeah so I mean
so the votes are coming in now Fly Me to
the Moon is you know clearly the
it's the favorite it's a fantastic video
it's it's insane uh acting mean though I
will say
for a simply put video it's at 14 is
getting a lot the acting meme
showing a lot better than the last
bracket
so there that is Fly Me to the Moon with
72 percent six thousand votes and I
think we can lock that up
yeah I don't think anybody's surmounting
this lead actually I'm happy to say that
so far there hasn't been like a
heartbreak in a big bracket we're two
really good ones
or I mean they're all good but like
these two that we've selected are really
really they're both very high effort
yeah so I don't without watching them
both back
um we've got Ethan
saves Palestine
versus Fly Me to the Moon should I play
a little clip or does everyone I think
everybody remembers them it's just so
hard I mean wow these golly all right
this is a semi-final round one and it is
uh Ethan saves Palestine versus
Fly Me to the Moon Man I
I have a hard time picking a favorite
between these two they're both so well
executed great concept
Alfie McGrath says can you watch mine I
don't know well uh we'll we'll look for
it it might we're only halfway through
yeah you might be in here yeah that's
true we're only halfway through this all
right so here we go they sure don't
final is going up and I really
as anybody's guess I don't know okay so
uh Ethan says Palestine I'm on the train
you've got those incredible green screen
edits with uh shirtless Eddie you've got
Jimmy Lee there and then Fly Me to the
Moon is that amazing original a Nook
song
you know cyberpunk go into space it's
worth mentioning too by the way that uh
these are all these are all winners
because we're already this is part of
the top four here oh so you guys already
is the cat they're already in there
congratulations yeah that's a good point
and I guess the winner of this goes is
one or two I don't know how we decided
exactly yeah I guess we'll do the other
half of the bracket and then we'll have
the final at the very end they've won
the Nobel Prize so
at the moment with 7 000 votes in it's
63 Fly Me to the Moon
and I gotta say
that one is just it is breathtaking Fly
Me to the Moon is just a [__] I can't I
can't disappear 53 but it is close I
mean 37 of the people like saves you
think saves Palestine and they're both
just
so so so good but with a you know a 22
point spread
I think we can safely call it I think
the moon has it
Fly Me to the Moon advances to the
finals safe Moon's going to the Moon
but I want to do a huge congratulations
to Juicy Reuben sandwich
he advances to the finals
and then
uh or no sorry sorry sorry correction
bees from space advances to the finals
and juicy reuben sandwich
congratulations you've you've played you
got a medal
third and fourth third slash fourth yeah
I mean we should just say three and four
it's just third they're both third place
sure exactly yeah yeah so congrats dude
oh my God
who's ready for the next bracket uh can
we actually take a breather for a minute
use the restroom go ahead I gotta pee
too
so that is the first 16.
this is so fun this is so exciting
[Music]
hey we're actually 16.
side note are you watching Attack on
Titan Tonight Ethan wait
I didn't know that yeah they split the
remaining episodes into two Mega
episodes one is out now and the other
one is to be determined I believe how
long is it it's an hour long
have you watched it already I'm watching
it right now I'm kidding nice uh but no
I have not watched yet it came out
actually right when we went live I
believe
[Music]
that's exciting yeah
fun yeah I'm definitely gonna watch it I
didn't know I don't know how I missed
that
where do you watch it
um this is on Crunchyroll
you have a Crunchyroll thing I made it
just for this usually I watch on uh
what's the other one uh
FUNimation you have FUNimation it's not
on FUNimation no it's not there yet it's
only on Crunchyroll right now how long
do I gotta wait because I use FUNimation
I give you my login
[Music]
that's weird because they're I thought
they're like the same company
yeah that's what I thought too I don't
know maybe it will be out by the time
we're done I love Funimation
[Music]
oh here's some little uh Andrew Tate
updates for you guys
I think okay so I saw those
I hope they don't hinder the the
upcoming green screen
videos
what the the Tate updates
I was worried that they may hinder the
viewing experience for the upcoming
green screen why
[Music]
just let me know if you want to stop the
show Dad at any other time when I'm
doing a bit go ahead I'm sorry well I
thought you were gonna okay go ahead
thank you uh so X so Andrew Tate is
rumored to have cancer
this is it's almost confirmed though is
it really yeah Andrew Tate has a dark
spot on his lungs most likely a tumor
influencer confirms major health fears
but says he's staying strong
as he is held in Romania over six
trafficking charges this man was so
cancerous he actually got cancer
I don't even know if I trust it though
to be honest with you he's not I don't
know he's not bring me pizza hello
telling lies no and also the cancer
narrative is gonna buy him sympathy
exactly
I mean obviously not for me
well this article says his doctors have
requested he returns to Dubai for
further exactly there you go bro this he
doesn't I'd be surprised if he has
cancer this man is just trying to get
out of prison exactly everyone died like
they've tried everything he's ass is
stuck in prison
he's you know probably paid off a doctor
to come in and say he has a dark spot on
his lung
because he's Beyond to get cancer and I
know about this whole tape thing it also
seems odd um because the thing that I
saw that was going around it said it was
like a doctor in Dubai or something so I
guess this was supposedly before he like
he he's known that he's had cancer for a
while
and has yeah been secretive about it and
been smoking guards ever since right and
like not not that he just found out I
need to to believe that I need to see
like an x-ray from like six months ago
because right now
he is Young how old is he
uh he's like in his mid-30s
I mean he smokes cigars 36. getting lung
cancer
getting lung cancer at that age from
smoking cigars is
really odd I mean it's really unusual
and cigar smoke usually causes mouth
cancer because you don't inhale it right
but uh love says both Romanian and Dubai
doctors have said it so I mean it sounds
like it's a thing Andrew Tate's manager
confirms reports that he's diagnosed
with lung cancer his manager would lie
for him though his this is his manager
apparently uh okay a lot of people so
what you think it's a play to just get
him out and then he'll flee he'll flee
the country he just wants to get out of
prison I don't know what his game is
after that but he wants to get out to
get treated he says okay A lot of people
are asking me if Tate lung cancer story
is true yes it's true I was the one
driving him to the to and from the
hospital in Dubai I don't have any more
specifics to share it I mean his manager
is not I'm sorry credible
this is another one good news team
Romanian news saying Tate actually did
have the biopsy that Dubai specialist
recommended it was done a month ago
and it says the tumor is benign
be really nice if this was leaked
earlier oh I bet it would be nice no
family and friends were extremely
concerned Romania wouldn't lie about
this so he's okay so he's okay so it's a
benign tumor it sounds like it's just
kind of a non-story then that is
interesting it's just a total non-story
it's 50 50. the man has a benign tumor
who cares he's trying to get out of
prison for a benign tournament
hell no
I mean you have better you have better
luck just saying I am cancer let me out
suck a little bit of dick I am the human
embodiment of cancer
I need treatment
thank you Nick Clark for the 20 gifts
that is so nice thank you
there is apparently the world ending
outside again yeah so many sirens so it
turns out
um why what dude how [__] incompetent
are these news agencies quote unquote
news Andrew Tate diagnosed with lung
cancer literally the top comment oh boy
is he has a benign tumor this Daily Mail
article too it says that the spokesman
person said Tate has a dark spot on his
lung most likely a tumor so if they
haven't even tested the tumor yet they
don't know if it's cancerous bro they're
just they're different they've never
tested it but it sounds like they did
and then it was benign
is this real though I don't know what's
real all I know is that he's full of
[__] he's getting out for this he's
trying to get out of prison no idea and
it sounds like he ain't got cancer too
so good luck you know at least if you
did have cancer you could blame
something up for that [__] disgusting
hairline I'm the one getting plowed look
at the chemo yeah I mean if you were
getting chemo at least you could have
something to say for this
[__] you ain't got no excuse brother
all right Andrew Tate is gonna live so
gonna be okay people thank you that's uh
I'm so relieved
thank you
all right I got to be uh move onward to
I gotta pee
we still didn't go okay yeah I'll be
right take care of business love
actually had a good great point he said
let's do this Tate thing for social
media and he's so right love he's so
right he's on the ball this guy is
knocked in the biz people and I so
appreciate that because you're right
yeah
thank you no I'm gonna I'm Gonna Be The
Daily Mail of tick tock thanks that's it
that's it Andrew dying of cancer a
million views easy all right I'll be
right back how bad you have to pee right
now
it's the tumor rumor nice nice when I
saw the news last night I said it oh
he's uh Andrew prostate cancer uh got
him before I saw I hadn't seen that it
was lung cancer I just saw the cancer
yeah Danny son of a [__] I thought it
was pretty good
sorry love I didn't see your note about
that whenever I was trying to stop Ethan
I uh it's all good because I there
I don't want to give away which one's my
favorite but one of the videos
[__] it I just give it away that's
really good Ethan kind of [__] up Tate
and I just I didn't want anything to
interfere with this masterpiece if it
was like sad oh that it was like
we would be too respectful it would be
too respectful of it yeah yeah that's
not this show
that's true yeah that's what you're
saying on that Ultra girl for a while
and I was I wanted to put it in before
but I knew the segment was too long and
then everyone went to pee and I was like
this is my time no no it was good juicer
time yeah it's time for time dude this
show would have looked completely
different had full control
the day Andrew Tate dies of cancer I'll
light up a cigar in his honor too
smoking on that wackback bro
hope you die in his honor
go [__] yourself in hell yeah well
doesn't look like you'll be doing that
anytime soon yeah well you know where
you will never work in dream you will
never see Andrew Tate
was that Zach Lewis live at the Roxy May
13th I've never seen Andrew Tate there
that's true
you want tickets
go on like hot fondue
last La show
ever
for right now retirement show retirement
show yes last La I've been Hub where
we're doing different cities after this
and do that all the time they retire
like every couple years to sell tickets
say it's a farewell tour farewell Zach
Lewis
goodbye L.A but seriously yeah this is
probably gonna be the last Lily show for
a while so um you want your tickets can
get them a good time
but I usually all there I used to work
at as a ticket Usher at a big Stadium
concert venue and I feel like TV Garden
no it was the [__] Xfinity Center
dude oh dude and I think I saw Motley
Crue's retirement tour two years in a
row right 2015.
and then they're on tour now they're
Motley Crue that was probably pretty
wild right like don't they do like
insane [__] I was bored I hated working
there you know and it sounds like it
would be fun to work a uh concert venue
but no no no you just deal with the
wrong people and you want to be drunk
with them but you have to be there you
have to be the bad guy Zach you know who
I saw at the Roxy right after they
dropped their first single ever in like
2012.
Ariana Grande wow intimate show you're
the next Ari here we go man so if you
want to see the farewell tour
of Zach Lewis well I'll be there I'll be
there you should start advertising as
that on your social media yeah
I see the chat saying Ethan's tweeting
what's uh oh man
oh oh I am I am okay
why does it lie
oh why does it lie the way how quickly
you were like no oh yeah it was just a
reply to the um green screen
just a picture
I saw a funny actually tweet by Mr Beast
I want to show you guys it's in the
Discord Mr Beast
oh boy
[Music]
man this man is literally
putting his fans to [__] slave labor
bro I need your help next time you see
Feast bowls in Walmart and soon to be
other retail can you please clean up the
presentation for me and make it look
nice
I'm building a team to do this routinely
but I just need help in the short term
yeah this is a real tweet
it's so upsetting to him to see the the
end caps uh disorganized he he you know
there's going to be hordes of people
that are gonna go
they're just going to be there all day
because there's people so dedicated to
him and want to be noticed by him so bad
because they could win like a million
dollars so weird I swear to God there's
gonna be like one kid in every Walmart
in the whole country excuse me
please don't mess up Mr BEAST's candy Mr
Beast told me to come out here and keep
an eye on his candy Eddie what are you
doing with their shirt off cleaning up
Mr BEAST's candy you gotta put your
shirt on I love cleaning up Mr Beast
candy with my shirt off
I don't think I've ever seen an
influencer ask anything like this of
their fans Game Changer there we are at
the next level
it'd be like ask them to mess up the
competitors
yeah that's a good one Mr Beast candy
bar challenge clean them up that'd be
like hey David Dober being like hey next
time you're at dobricks can you all just
like sweep the front of it
make it look nice
and while you're at it if you want to
maybe move some Hershey bars and make
sure feasible has plenty of space okay
that's not even a joke yeah it's
sabotaging that's a genuine request
holy [__] I mean
what the [__] I wouldn't complain if you
go uh [__] up the competition a bit you
know and then people are posting
pictures now look at the pictures below
the before and after
click that easy
damn he did that so easy easy notice
damn you clean that [__] right up
in labor a [__] dumped on those candy
bars this is this is really something
you know what I think it's
kind of reasonable it's kind of what
it's a reasonable Ash just a little
cleanup
you don't think it's odd like it's like
the worst thing in the world but
did you take up sorry I forgot you're
the community King
I can't see your shot so I don't
I'm assuming you took a bite of crunch
of Beast bar yep that would be yeah
is that the um hilarious the nuts one
no it's not we ordered the nut one but
it didn't come in they accidentally sent
us the wrong package it was addressed to
someone else whoa he should get his team
on that but we did get them yeah we did
get the nut stickers though I'm
surprised some like 12 year old unpaid
12 year olds like hey I heard that you
got the wrong box let me let me take
care of that for you no there no no
they're at the Fulfillment center
they're at FedEx hey real quick can I
look through the truck real quick and uh
just make sure these are all dress
correct one second Mr Beast can be like
hey if you guys stop by our fulfillment
center can you go in there and just give
them a hand we have a lot of orders and
uh we need to get them out
this is kind of psycho yeah no this this
bar really does suck too by the way
actually can I get a bite of that yeah
I'm just so hungry that's the classic
one
I mean dude if you want just make better
chocolate
oh thank you so much
okay I'm hungry Joe submit Chad said
there's a huge police chase in LA right
now I wonder if we heard that's what we
heard yeah
you know it is good it's just the rest
of the tournament
is that who just read by us
the windshield now I'm doing joined by
David Ono or
91.00 and David been watching this very
dangerous Pursuit on a Friday that guy's
last name is Ono to have him driving
through surface streets at 100 miles an
hour close this [__] before we started
shooting right there somebody died
that guy's last name is oh no
it's not bad I think he oversells it
that's the problem
all right well
um guys
if you
if you see anyone wearing Teddy fresh
can you um
just stop and tell them about the sale
and just let them know no it'd be more
like if you see anybody wearing Teddy
fresh if you got a like a lint roller if
you could just turn them up a little bit
straighten out the collar make sure it's
laying flat yeah I just wanted to be
presented to the world thank you I don't
want I don't want the clothes it looks
like [__]
because I know our fans don't wash their
clothes
funny stuff let's move on move on to
part two
congratulations to the first bracket
dude this is this is disturbing like
when you zoom out
all right you see what I'm talking about
yeah that
looks like a b-hole
all right here we go round two begins
now
Ethan versus A.I Ethan he may have felt
relieved to finally get that off his
chest that through your therapy I no
longer have to lie about having
Tourette's in reality you guys got
scammed yeah no people are asking I
brought I had a doctor's letter a
neurologist that I saw when I was a kid
saying that I had Tourette's they wanted
to come they wanted me to come tick for
them like a
thank you
where am I
oh my God
prepare to fight
[Music]
three two one fight
this guy is too powerful how am I
supposed to beat him
um
uh
yeah
[Music]
wait I think I've got it let's see how
you handle this
impressive you win
okay wow
another Super Creative entry
um
I'm impressed with the direction they
took it didn't see that one coming so
that is the um can you highlight where
we are in the document please uh that
was number 17.
by
usuru all right up against Ethan fever
dream meme take a look
[Music]
it's almost
but you can't even do that locker room
today that cop wasn't playing that I
mean
you're lucky
that looked awesome with the roll
[Music]
okay
where am I
welcome home
it's time to go
pretty clever
[Music]
nice very good
very fun very creative again
that was by Michelle memes with H3 in
the title so let's put it to the test
here we've got
um fever dream versus AI Ethan uh verse
real Ethan take a look
round nine two great videos thank you
both
let's have a look here
okay
votes are pouring in
early looking like 80 fever dream with
2500 votes there are 76 fever dream 25
Ethan versus AI Ethan
uh we'll give it a couple seconds here
but I think we know who's gonna win this
one
I think we can call it with 4 000 votes
that's fever dream
Ethan was 72 thank you
thank you to both
[Applause]
us you're you who's averse
usuru
his full name is Lucifer's I know it's a
part of the community
uh up next comatose Ethan
versus Nathaniel Klein he's fighting
very hard but you need to have realistic
expectations Ethan hey [__] talk now
that hilo's use is awesome
yo put your hands up
put your hands up I'm not gonna ask you
again
I'm just in the podcast I lost a couple
weights and I love having my shirt
listen
I got nothing to do with that you
understand
[Music]
beautiful
hey you come out here often nice to see
you out here in the club
just forget about everything tonight
tonight's just about the boys
[Music]
open up FBI
stop right there
this guy over here is cooked all
different flavors
anyway I want to give a shout out to my
wife Chelsea who [__] my cousin over
the weekend [__] now my whole life is
look at the size of that
that is enormous
I have never seen something that big
holy smokes
don't [__] with me I got a gun in my
glove box
foreign
[Music]
everything seems so real what could
possibly be causing you to construct
this artificial reality wake up wake up
that's one of the few I had seen
beforehand and I was I'm Blown Away by
that one I mean it's so funny the whole
Odyssey
use almost every like different section
of the footage that you made so cool so
good so that is beautiful up next we got
Nathaniel klansman looking forward to
this one let's take a look
why is it muted it doesn't make sense
[Music]
expression we have to keep our country
gay but it's not
right overs
I tell you what man Trump is the best
President we ever had he's still
president before I tell you what
fighting Scooby
hey Granny get up the road you old hag
sir look what you did in my car
I got a gun hey deep cut you want to see
the business end of a Nerf gun you
better back up bucko
[Music]
oh no killed by Nick ocado
wow what a tragic ending
Clansman
Dan pointed out in that last video I had
this one right over my head
um the audio of me getting in that car
accident is in that way oh here it is I
got it gone hey
oh [__]
hey Granny get off the road
Rodeo sir look what you did in my car oh
my God
that is the craziest recall ever yeah
you know some props to them that that's
pretty cool
wow
when I heard that I was like that must
be he recorded that
yeah I know that's Zack he was a deep
deep cut well there it is let's throw it
to the vote the vote is up what do the
people think comatose Ethan versus
Nathaniel Klein who is unfortunately
slain
by Nick ocado
while the votes were pouring again we
have 5 000 votes and 65 percent comatose
Ethan I think I'm comfortable calling it
at this point 35 Nathaniel Klein thank
you
to both
rmd
462 who made comatose and really dead
who made Nathaniel Klein thank you thank
you
up next is Anime intro this one
interests me by go Cody
let's take a look
I love this [__]
[Music]
let's go
ah nice
[Music]
that was fun that was awesome that was a
fun one man that 44 seconds went by so
fast that was great
I want to watch that show I'm going to
be in that show
I wish I was in that show anime uh intro
versus Channel
surfing fever dream hmm
here we go just just make it seem more
generic hey fit hey Philly watch out
hide your kidneys
God you're beautiful
damn girl I hate that damn cool that's
disgusting
been resurrected some kind of robot I
don't see you very much I'm here all the
time just let it go
just forget about everything work with
me
um
oh
foreign
I can feel the burn
wow fun creative
I like that I like that they they
created their own reason to just get
random and it was fun man that was a
good one
so that puts us up against anime versus
channel surfing that's right all right
I'm putting it up this round 11.
and see how it goes
here we go
anime first channel surfing
that's a hard one
they were both they got them they got
them
I'm nervous when you pull that up
because
those people like blow their brains out
live yeah it's over
I remember when I was a kid they used to
broadcast these live chases mm-hmm
I mean they still do there was one dude
who blew his brains out in the freeway
remember that yep they showed it it sure
did yeah they uh they always when it
seems like it's coming to an end they
zoom out like uh so stupid that's the
part we want
Showdown
so let's take a look at the vote here uh
it's fairly close
um anime is in the lead but it's much
tighter than a lot of these rounds have
been well
we have 7 000 votes casts 57 anime 43
channel surfing
it's close but I feel comfortable
calling it for anime
uh channel surfing was so phenomenal I
mean the Howie head uh
spitting out slug I hated that [__] I
like that image that made me so
uncomfortable
great job to everybody though go Cody
and pixel face official thank you guys
so much
next bracket the swap trailer the swap
trailer meme by big puffy the swap
trailer meme you know in today's society
we'll go through a lot of hard
times
[Music]
join me on this journey
the Swap this is beautiful
where's that
oh that's a hell on Earth no big one
no hey Granny get off the road you old
hat
I tell you what boy
comment on my property
[Music]
foreign
I would like to inform you we took the
body yo
and we chopped it up
and then you ate
God you're beautiful
talk to me baby
I have decided
remove this head
[Music]
I just like it
It's Gonna Stop Me wow
I don't think so
that was so good
creative original
he created his own Universe I loved that
so much that picture uh wow what a movie
a compelling plot line perhaps for a
Hollywood Blockbuster I think let's
Finance it so that was let's find the
whole picture man yeah I'm in man I just
need maybe Ryan Kavanaugh will get in on
this I need some big some big heavy
movers he's in the horror movie scene
now too
uh big puffy made that one thank you up
against gamer Ethan saves the crew okay
I like this
oh oh oh
foreign
I'm doing a little uh enter dragon
moving up the bosses
for combat
wow
severe and continuous laughs awesome
loving it
Pink's magic all different flavors
he's selling me good yeah that's
disgusting
taking a little break
oh [__] I love him
this is freaking awesome yeah it's
really well done
okay we got full health
oh no not
lost it
I'm here to slaughter the lawsuit
died lawsuit
[__] these
okay
you did pretty good on the keys until
you gave up yeah right
oh yeah
[Applause]
it looks like we're celebrating with a
bunch of fika fish
thank you for watching I did this
instead of prepping for my career fair I
hope you're proud of me Mom
thank you Veronica W who needs a job
anyway yeah Veronica dub
uh thank you excellent so much fun
all right throwing it up this is round
12. so we've got the swap versus uh
gamer Ethan
a lot of fun you know
um both of them
it's actually close up
early vote shows a close race here swap
trailer
sixty percent gamer Ethan 41 it's moving
up 41. so this one we're gonna have to
let the vote run in here a little bit
it's 58 swap trailer 43 gamer Ethan
the gamer Ethan surprised me
it got more and more fun as it went
along I agree the swap trailer though
it's kind of a creative force to be
recognized I wanted to see that movie by
the end I'm in I was in
so
not much move in here with 6 000 votes
in 53 swap trailer 43 gamer Ethan I'm
comfortable calling it at this point
thank you both congratulations to swap
trailer and thank you to um
what was her name Veronica Veronica you
you you skipped the career fair for
nothing
should have got a job she [__] up
just kidding that was fun it was awesome
thank you Veronica W as Amy said
uh moving on
Ethan at the streamies okay here I am
I'm into this
guys on the internet
it's Jay Shetty [__] you Shetty
[Music]
I'm passing am I right
exactly tonight I have the honor of
introducing a very special award creator
for social good presented by the Elevate
prize Foundation Jake Shetty you'll be
selling avocado ghosts
I'm charging him
[Applause]
oh
if you're talking about what Ethan did
oh great it has to get better at
controlling incorporating real drama
I got it gone
don't [__] with me I gotta go to my
glove box
breaking news at Santa Monica where a
suspect is refusing to surrender after a
police pursuit
[Music]
thank you
Hey listen
I got PMP in my lawyer you understand
yep hey keep me that's the only one
there for me
I don't know I'm not recording it we're
Gabe's there oh you're recording it
oh no not fake Ethan no
tucked again ah Ian misses me that's
nice
and thank you guys it's nice to know you
miss
you missed so bad
[Music]
artsy jokes nice it's a good thing I
never went to the streaming otherwise
yeah we would have lost it all
uh thank you so so much that was
phenomenal artsy chokes
America's Got Talent next by Drew Noel
let's have a look
there
[Applause]
[Music]
well that's the spirit
okay I cannot wait to see what you're
gonna do right here
looks so good with the the reflection
Feel The Beat just forget about
everything and I tonight's just about
the boys
just forget about it all man just let it
go
oh yeah
I'll be my biggest fan
forget about everything
just forget about everything
tonight's about the boys
dude that's awesome
he's intrigued by this part hit that
pretty boy
hit that gritty nice and low
oh
is anyone still watching
yeah I understand that
nice awesome the way they did the
reflection on the stage made it look so
real and and uh fantastic with a really
shitty green screen
they made that look awesome so Drew Noel
we've got our bracket here Streamys
versus America's Got Talent
thank you by the way to David Whispers
meeting time got to go have a great
weekend getting an all entrants today
are sick with Talent just absurd stand
the inner child thank you David
shout out to your inner child bro shout
out thank you David
all right we got the steamies versus the
talent oh golly
huh
all right 5 000 votes in 65 percent
going to the streamies
35 to America's Got Talent it's pretty
close but we've got a clear winner here
all righty
in the Streamys so thank you Shetty wins
again
[__] Shady bro he stays winning if he
wins this whole thing I'm gonna be
pissed
Jay Shetty [__] you you win actually
thank you to um artsy chokes there
moving on next bracket we've got
convenience store by Jay the star let's
take a look
oh this is from uh Twin Peaks in it a
shot
the new one
oh [__]
I'm loving this Rigby it's clever I
haven't seen it yet
I tried crack once
[Laughter]
goodbye crap
do we know who that is
huh
sure yeah you want to come in my car and
Tangle with the crack
hell can I have a burger with lack of
jalapeno and pineapple please I hate
that it's so weird
yeah you you're joining in I can feel
the burn
oh it's some kind of meme photo
oh that was good
whoa
[Music]
babe are you okay
[Laughter]
that was good super fun
wow
that would be uh Jay the star convenient
tripping balls at the convenience store
next up by Austin FST the trials of
Ethan oh golly you put me on trial
ah
you don't want to be like this
this is disgusting this is awful in
every way that's disgusting I can't
believe even a second I'm being judged
myself precisely
because such things matter when the
accusations start flying
we'll see who cancels
violated rule oh
hey Ethan weird I've never seen you in
the prolapse Dimension I snorted too
much Alpha grind 9000 the effects are
similar to DMT it's pretty mellow listen
things seem pretty [__] up down there
the space-time Continuum has been a
little out of whack since
wait are you eating chips Ethan stop
eating chips
Ethan's wild I could be taking a risk
but I think you're our best shot at this
I'm sending you to a powerful Oracle
that can Aid you in your journey of
rebalancing the universe Jamie pull up
the quantum tunnel
no
look at the size of that thing right
there holy smokes
they're two of us
[Music]
oh [__] that looks awesome
did I just 911 Twitter headquarters
we did we [__] did
you sons of [__] so you absorb the
powers of the chestnut Oracle did you
I'll take care of this beta male I'm
gonna squeeze his [__] with my soft lips
let's go
yo got a [__] itchy [__] I'm here
to slaughter the children no oh the
apple cider [__] these kids right if I
could kill it I would yeah I'm doing all
I can no how is this possible
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow that was a journey yep that was
amazing what an experience that was the
one you were talking about Evie
that you loved they'd only have 49 votes
what's going on here is that insane 49
votes on the subreddit people dude that
shot of Hassan is it just because it's
too long that people don't
late at night or something it's it you
know it's always a crap shoot when you
post something thank you Ian for putting
in the work to find these that that
is just incredible yeah I'm glad this
guy's getting some shine he's put in a
lot of work what were you saying maybe
oh just that shot of Hassan being blown
away so far and then the keemstar
screaming on this gun
the nuke destroying the city being a
Nook like it just like reveals oh [__]
the nuke I didn't even put two and two
together hey do we have food updates Sam
let's [__] go I'm starting the timer
now
also all the use of the AI voices the AI
Elon the AI Joe Rogan so good yeah the E
the Elon AI sounded crazy good the
Tate's saying um I mean fights so that
was amazing by the way
you say I'm gonna put my soft lips they
got his weird-ass accent too okay
he might have actually said that for
real nice yeah
what's he gonna do sue me from prison
probably actually he could
it's not a good defense
he did not say that yeah the dead though
just saying what Robin
you can't you can't defame the Dead
which is crazy because if he dies I'm
gonna go buckle why
isn't that I find it kind of crazy that
you can't defame the dead I it's very I
mean it's not even something people say
is that even true it is true let me fact
check that once
when I was in fifth grade and Osama Bin
Laden was killed our teacher got very
upset with us and sat us down and said
you cannot you cannot celebrate
someone's death and we were like
you can celebrate Osama
um no you cannot defame the dead you
cannot dinosaurs you cannot sue them it
was just crazy because it affects so
many people but there you go like
Michael Jackson he's like a
what haven't I said about Michael
Jackson that's true but I can't defame
him anyway that was incredible let's
throw it up to the vote
not to be a dick to convenience store
because it was so good that was a great
one it just happened to go up against
what is probably a finals Contender
possibly a finals Contender although of
all the other like really high high high
tier ones
the convenience store one still got 17
18 now it's changing a little bit but
ultimately the trial of Ethan is locking
it up easily seven thousand votes 82
percent thank you to a convenience store
yeah and again but like Ian said before
he went through
250-ish of these and this is the top 32
so
well I made it this far you're already a
winner people I was afraid this segment
was gonna be too long and I told Ian
just a limp we don't need 32 just
eliminate some and he says
they're all good I can't take a lot of
good ones yeah and you're right you were
right Ian
I'm telling up there
okay so thank you to Jay the star and uh
congratulations to Austin FST
up next Ethan versus Jimmy Lee
you know I like this okay
that is enormous
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm giving you a direct order to take
out that Bugatti
what the hell
that is funny
[Music]
clouds are going to be passing by no
rain
[Music]
[Applause]
open up FBI
no put your hands up put them up when
you [__] started
Luigi's dumbass
it was a trap
Jimmy Lee was behind the whole thing
stop him he liked my hand from Pink
tacos I don't know if I mentioned
[Music]
fun wow awesome excellent stuff
that was fun man
a character
wow that's an old video yeah you know
what's weird nobody's done the
Ratatouille
I did like the whole Ratatouille thing
and nobody went for it
maybe the footage wasn't it just wasn't
hitting yeah
congrats to the Jersey Lawman yo that's
the journey is that the actual Jersey
law man no it is yeah yeah it is Yo
[__] Legend
wow we know about you we're her fans oh
he knows I like literally all of his
bows
shout out jersey Lawman way better than
Jersey Outlaw yeah [__] the outlaw we
know we love the Llama we gotta ask Jim
if he knows about the Jersey Law minute
I he knows he knows does he he doesn't
he doesn't like it
well he steals the memes from the Jersey
law man too yeah because he's the outlaw
he steals the memes this is um uh Andrew
Tate shortly after rub wrapping his soft
lips
shout out to Ryan or Harvick I remember
uh thank you Andrew
that was a good one we love you Jersey
law man
up next are verses
cutie Cinderella chestnuts oh God
so I haven't screened this one but thank
you baby Ian wouldn't have put it in
there if it was uh if this is gonna make
me look like a dick or make her feel bad
right oh this is
uh no I'm here I
it's saying what you did was wrong
essentially okay what the [__] are these
Tate screenshots dude dude Ryan or
Harvey he is so good at finding funny
screenshots of people he is very
talented
Andrew Tate is really enjoying prison
life what is the lifestyle where did
this come from apparently he took a
shower on a private yet at some point
and this is a video from him
wow
all right so moving on
dude ugh
all right Ian put this in not me oh my
God he's true this is how I think
everyone the whole world wishes it
happened this is meme okay okay
[Music]
I see it's the intrusive thought
are you trying to fight it off
okay
[Music]
I support her
nice that is a beautiful alternate
exactly that's exactly how it went down
actually
that's how I remember it actually
nice little end card there too
I dream of a world where
that's what happened
okay I see the point so thank you too
ishid Bubba
Isha Baba so we got two really strong
entries here
going Head to Head
we got
where are we Ethan versus Jimmy Lee
versus uh uh cutie Cinderella chestnuts
meme all right let's see it the vote is
up and the early lead to Ethan versus
Jimmy
oh my God stop sending videos
too funny here's more Andrew Tate
bukakis
it's not that to be clear that is water
H2O yeah it's just shower
just taking bro where I didn't even
think to do this even wild man
all right to the votes uh chi whiz Ethan
and Jimmy willikers first cutie weeping
lizards
all right we got 5 000 votes in it's 68
Jimmy
verse Ethan and thank you guys I don't
think I can handle cutie Cinderella
winning this
I don't want any of that yeah
I got nothing to do with that hey hey
I don't know nothing about nobody all
right here's the last one and then we're
moving to the semi it's the last
normal Round Round 16. We Made It evil
Joe Biden
Joe Biden has ran this country into the
ground crime and poverty has filled
these streets chaos is everywhere he's
still president but I tell you what
that Joe Biden been resurrected some
kind of robot
he ain't right
[Music]
wow
I am that storm
let's go hey bye
now die
leaving my friendships bye oh wow it was
you
why doesn't take a rocket surgeon
anything oh wow are you wasting your
time on these these uh
[Laughter]
naive you are thinking I was the only
one when my friend Biden bent over this
happened does somebody know is this
covid reloaded no and if it is what do
we do about it
ow
that was insane wow that was dope
that was insane
wow that was evil Biden
by next
nobody
next nobody
all right here's the final new one and
then we're gonna move on Blade Runner
meme okay kind of a similar uh welcome
everybody happy Tuesday we got a warm
system coming in which means hot weather
all around the Midwest anyway I want to
give a shout out to my wife Chelsea who
[__] my cousin over the weekend [__]
now my whole life is raining and it's
your fault I hope you [__] die
um
[Music]
you want it gone erase everything all
Trace
pull your hands up I'm not gonna ask you
again
foreign
[Music]
wait I have a gift for you
wow
that was really slick that looks so good
oh that was an insanely good at it
nice
interesting
I got a very creative approach
wow those ones are really strong you
know
um
let's throw it to the polls evil Biden
versus Blade Runner
I have a feeling blade runner's gonna
lose but if it was up against anything
else man that'd be a dub because that
you know
let's see let's throw it let's throw it
I saw some people asking a chat about
the Twilight one that did get copyright
claims unfortunately so we had a oh I
use it there was a good one I had to
exclude yeah yep it used Too Much clips
from the movie yeah and we got copyright
claims thank you guys for checking that
thank you Ian the Eagle Eye Ian once
again
thank you Ian you did amazing amazing no
problem
it was really good though so whoever
made that one shout out
if there's a way to change I don't know
if there's a way to change it or
so it's like less copyright
whatever
oh next nobody donated said love you all
glad you saw my edit which one was next
to nobody's uh that's the one that just
won Evo Biden
um
congratulations
I didn't see the pool but I think it was
like 70 30. yeah it was winning
comfortably so I ended it next nobody
advances thank you to
fosu
YouTuber I'm assuming it's YouTube White
team
all right so here's what's happening now
we have
our semi-finalists
quarter final quarter finalists and this
is going to decide the finals
so like before I'm going to play each
four Once one time
and then we'll vote on all four
so
um
why do we have
it's a after this divider so if you go
starting with Ethan's fever dream and
then all the green ones
oh right it's four
four two rounds of four
we didn't watch them all in this round
we just voted didn't we
I watch no you recapped them
last time you don't have to if you don't
want to but we watched all eight of them
I thought we just watched on the
quarters oh you're right you're right I
remember
the quarters we did not watch exactly
so let's do that then we're gonna watch
them all and we voted for the four got
it exactly all right so Ethan's fever
dream versus comatose Ethan oh the two
tripping ones
[Music]
but you can't even do that locker room
today that cop wasn't playing that I
mean
you're lucky you only got battery what
if he
[Music]
where am I
welcome home
it's time to go
in the floating
[Music]
awesome
that's the fever dream up against the
other fever dream
comatose Ethan
Battle of the dream sequences he's
fighting very hard but you need to have
realistic expectations Ethan hey [__]
talk now
yo put your hands up
put your hands up I'm not gonna ask you
again
I'm just in the podcast I lost a couple
weights and I love having my shirt
listen
I got nothing to do with that you
understand yeah
[Music]
this is beautiful
hey you come over here often nice to see
you out here in the club
just forget about everything and I
tonight's just about the boys
[Music]
stop right there
this guy over here is cooked all
different flavors
anyway I want to give a shout out to my
wife Chelsea who [__] my cousin over
the weekend [__] now my whole life is
look at the size of that
that is enormous
I have never seen something that big
holy smokes
don't [__] with me I got a gun in my
glove box
[Music]
everything seems so real what could
possibly be causing you to construct
this artificial reality wake up wake up
ah
that's a tough one
Battle of the fever dreams
oof and we have two more as well
right
okay up next
we've got
anime intro
[Music]
thank you
nice awesome
and then finally
the swap trailer
it's gonna change how you see everything
join me on this journey
[Music]
this is beautiful
where's that screen
hey Granny get off the road you old hat
You're Gonna Hate Me
I tell you what boy
oh comment on my property again you hear
me
[Music]
that is a legendary transition right
there Hey listen I got nothing to do
with that
I wish I could just wipe out the whole
world of these peasants as the executive
chef of this restaurant I would like to
inform you we took the body yo
and we chopped it up
and then you ate
God you're beautiful
talk to me baby
[Music]
I have decided
his head
[Music]
[Applause]
I just like it
who's gonna stop me
I don't think so phenomenal
the music the editing operative
incredible so here's our first bracket
here
the fever dreams
so we got the fever dream and the
comatose the anime and the swap
these four
right here
pull should be going up all right
throwing it up thank you so much cole
for the gifted thank you for giving give
it a good skip thank you
so so much
now for me
it's it's they're all great but for me
there's obviously one that stands out
and I I it seems that everybody agrees
the swap the swap is powerful the swap
is powerful I think uh comatose Ethan I
would guess is going to come in second
because I was seeing a lot of love for
that one yeah it's at 17 but that's
pretty good up against the Behemoth like
swap yeah but um the swap
yeah I mean it's a it's a blowout
can you say
all right I trashed that burrito too yep
same bearing though
did you eat the wet you ate the whole
wet then you know I'm not complaining
because it was very good but it was
smaller than it could be yeah well
before it was too much fat it was almost
obscene yeah it's probably good so yes I
finished it and it was pretty much the
perfect amount of burrito yeah mine was
I'm gonna eat your ass
okay that's another burrito I guess
does anyone want some french fries I
can't finish these if you want something
french fries I got some french fries I'm
actually curious how are they from a
Mexican restaurant okay that's pretty
good sometimes the fries at the Mexican
place hit pretty hard when they got the
the season yeah they get dusted with
some what do you call that uh Mexican
salt
haha
with the red flags yeah
Mexican restaurants have bomb hamburgers
too for no reason
Mexican no reason food is just the best
man I don't know what to say I eat it
every night people think I'm like
funny for that but it is what it is man
just deal with it
uh okay um so the swap which is this one
right yeah that is moving on congrats to
the squad
congrats to everybody I mean yes that's
everyone
so amazing
thank you to uh Michelle H3 memes rmd
go Cody and our winner big puffy
okay here's the final one then we're
moving right on man
Ethan
at the Streamys by artsy chokes here we
go
the nicest guys on the Internet it's Jay
Shetty right this [__] dude there's so
many good ones God damn
[Applause]
hey everyone it's uh it's so awesome
that the stream is back in person am I
right
yeah it's awesome tonight I have the
honor of introducing a very special
award creator for social good presented
by the Elevate prize welcome Nation Jake
Shetty you'll be selling avocado toast
foreign
did he just has to get better at
controlling his urges
[Applause]
I got it done
don't [__] with me I got a gun in my
glove box
away
breaking news at Santa Monica where a
suspect is refusing to surrender after a
police pursuit
Hey listen
I got nothing to do Alfredo's in the
audience
I don't know nothing about nobody
ah
Aki I hate seeing fake Ethan there
[__] you dude
cheers
it's like you guys would really cry for
me like this if you went to jail for um
[__] J shed his evil ass
there it is Arts artsy chokes
powerful first entry
next one is the trials of Ethan
right by Austin FST
[Music]
you don't want to be like this
this is disgusting this is awful in
everything we get it Mark on YouTube
precisely
[Music]
because such things matter when the
accusations start flying
laughs
we'll see who cancels who
a
tweet finally it's where the rules
hey Ethan weird I've never seen you in
the prolapse Dimension I snorted too
much Alpha grind 9000 the effects are
similar to DMT it's pretty mellow listen
things seem pretty [__] up down there
the space-time Continuum has been a
little out of whack since
well wait are you eating chips Ethan
stop eating chip Ethan it's actually
listening to me right now I could be
taking a risk but I think you're our
best shot at this I'm sending you to a
powerful Oracle that can Aid you in your
journey of rebalancing the universe
Jamie pull up the quantum tunnel
no
[Music]
look at the size of that thing right
there oh please subscribe
the truth
uh
[Music]
hey Stingray I'm gonna need your help
down here [__] totally brought it on
ourselves dude holy [__] we did we
[__] did
sons of [__] so you absorb the powers
of the chestnut Oracle did you I'll take
care of this beta mail I'm gonna squeeze
his [__] with my soft lips I mean fight
him
that's so funny
thank you
it's got a [__] itchy [__] I'm
here to slaughter the children up yours
[__] these kids right if I could kill it
I would yeah I'm doing all I can no how
is this possible
[Music]
I love that effect
we did not save the world it looks like
yeah they picked the wrong guy really
picked the wrong guy wow so so good
how do you even decide the trials of
Ethan
um up next is Ethan versus Jimmy Lee
there it is
these last four are really strong man
that is enormous
[Music]
foreign
thank you
damn it come on that was Jay Leno he's
in the Bugatti by the train I hope you
[__] die
anyway it's coming in over the weekend
nice beautiful weather clouds are going
to be passing by no rain
I'm a sweaty [__] mess there
[Applause]
oh bro FBI
yo put your hands up put them up
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was a trap Jimmy Lee was behind the
whole thing stop him
he like my hat from Pink tacos I don't
know if I mentioned
[Music]
that's what Jimmy looks like without his
hair and makeup
very fun very good
Ethan for stimuli
a character
laughs
I don't even remember what this is from
to be honest with you
I remember that what is it it was you
found some Channel and it was a woman it
was like an ASMR or something well she
went to all the side boob and crazy
nudity yeah the redhead girl shot and
and she was doing something with carrots
okay the redhead of the girl yes I
remember I remember I remember yeah
that channel is Wild yeah
okay got it I remember I remember thank
you and finally
this is the last one we're gonna watch
evil Biden wait
is that right yeah
evil Biden by next nobody once again
the year is 2073. Joe Biden has ran this
country into the ground crime and
poverty has filled these streets chaos
is everywhere he's still president but I
tell you what
Joe Biden been resurrected some kind of
robot
he ain't right
yeah that is amazing but little does he
know a storm is coming I am that storm
Biden
now died
leaving my friendship
it was you
why he doesn't take a rocket surgeon
Ethan dude
my dad with this knife
[Music]
you are thinking I was the only one when
my friend Biden bent over this happened
does somebody know is this covid related
and if it is what do we do about it
ow
the head spinning into spider mode that
is a goddamn good at video
that might be the hardest quarterfinal
round yeah these four are all like all
they're all like odyssey's I mean just
huge huge hitters
all right but only one can be the winner
so so throw it up we've got basically
we've got evil Biden by next nobody
Jimmy verse Ethan by the Jersey law man
the trials of Ethan by Austin FST and
Ethan at the streamies by artsy chokes
I honestly God I don't know who to vote
for
this is crazy
yeah I really don't know which one I
would vote for
I guess
for me it's probably between the trials
and the evil biting me too I can't
decide though but I cannot decide
between those two yeah
the evil Biden one
the trials one was it ended so strong
you know the trials one
[__] I I can't it's a coin toss
oh I guess people weren't as conflicted
as we were
going over inflicted but you know you
got you gotta pick and
that's the one I actually ended up
voting for
the trials of Ethan got 48 percent
so that's a pretty decisive win evil
Biden got 22 percent Ethan at the stream
is 17 Ethan versus Jimmy 13 percent
this is just incredible
people are suggesting a runoff for this
category why
I mean I would say just because they're
such strong contenders but I mean it's
it's a pretty strong lead that the
trials has at this point nah Yeah so
basically at this point we have we're in
the finals
and I think we can say congratulations
to evil Biden who got third place
uh
uh no no no there's one more round
that's that's that's not correct
oh we have the brackets yes indeed so we
have so it would be uh [__] which one is
which I think that yeah this is the
trials so it's the trials
versus the winner of that previous
semi-final which was
uh the swap
the swap so it's the swap versus the
trials
it's another swap because we just
watched the well
the swap was like the
what was that movie where everyone
there's no laws for a day stupid Purge
such a dumb concept
yeah the per it's like a purge video
right the swap
so this will be the semi-finals round
two and it will be between the Swap and
the trials
of Ethan
these are so red I I hate to vote
because I honor you all so much
but go ahead this is it all right let's
see
[Music]
I didn't get the okay
hold up I have to cast my vote I hate to
do it
but there it is it's really close this
is going to be a very close one
everybody get your votes in because this
time it is close okay
the swap has a slight lead right now
[Music]
the swap is in first place but not by a
lot at all here's a video so Donald
Trump will someone shut that dude up
shut the [__] up Dash
the swap has fished shut up love you
dash
51 the swap it's narrowing it's 5 000
votes everybody please get your votes in
it matters now the trials of Ethan 49
the swap 51 it matters every vote count
every vote counts this is for the finals
between these two this is even tougher
than that I don't even want to say
because I don't want to influence okay
but the winners gonna square off against
um
the other side of the bracket which was
fly me to them I'm into the moon
fantastic entry Lee the swap is holding
a lead a lead at 51 but boy is it close
get those votes at only six thousand
come on we got more people than that get
your votes in people
34 000 of you watching right now I can't
call it with this close of a spread
we need at least ten thousand yeah I
think 10 is a good place to right now
we're at six thousand three hundred
fifty fifty that's it
wow this is too close it's 50 50. 10 000
DPI
this swap
burst the trials of Ethan it is 50 50. I
cannot believe what I'm saying
a stunning it's anybody's game
7 000 votes it's still 50 50. people get
your votes and it matters now more than
it ever has the winner goes up against
Fly Me to the Moon
a modern day masterpiece
come on they call them dumps
where is everybody there's 30 there's
almost 30 people 35 000 and you guys
can't get come on now
big massive dump it's 50 50. we're stuck
here until y'all vote
7 300 votes it's still dead heat 50 50.
swap versus the trails of Ethan I cannot
believe what I'm seeing coming with that
heat mm-hmm
boy technically although it is still
displaying 50 50 the trials has pulled
ahead in that how can you tell uh it oh
and the swap just it just swapped back
and swap wait how can you tell uh one of
them has a box around them uh maybe just
for me I don't know mine doesn't mind
yeah mine has a box over the one that's
actually winning and it keeps it's it's
it keeps going back and forth between
them now so some people are suggesting
and this might not be a terrible idea to
re-watch them both
because this is crazy this is a little
crazy I have a feeling if we re-watch
them both there'll be a clear winner
when people have them both fresh in
their minds but like it's 5 15 already
you guys
you said ten thousand votes I say at ten
thousand whoever that box is around even
if it's still 50 50 that's that's the
that's the winner
we got 8 100 votes it's still 50 50. I
can't believe this is maybe a thousand
more votes you can do it this might be
the closest poll we've had in the
history of polls
[Music]
trials we have 10 donation from James
blaze it says trials trials trials wow
people are throwing money on it we got
big fans here in the in the chat wow
re-watch lots of people saying how many
Waters
just so that they can get their input in
I mean there's no movement we're at
eight thousand three hundred fifty fifty
maybe we just need to re-watch I hate to
say it but it's a big deal it's a big
big oh [__] the trials took the lead 51
uh
very interesting answer the swap get in
here and vote 49 because Trials of ether
just took the lead 51 1500 more votes
somebody just donated 20 for a swap
dumps ten dollars from the architect for
swap for the w
itch swap swap the swap is losing and
lots of swap support in the donations
trials for the people from Emily C swap
is goat please from course swap people
have money
trials swappily trials swappily it's
going back and forth
five dollars from Blue McNeil swap was
lit as [__] but rewatched at two times
Speed Works okay
a bad suggestion watch it two times oh
it's back to 50 50. bro this is crazy oh
50 50. okay here's what I want to do
we're at nine thousand it's 50 50. this
is bananas maybe I'll just let it go to
ten let's go to ten let's see what
happens if there's if it's 50 50 when
it's 10 we're gonna have to go back and
re-watch them at times two speed ten
thousand DPI trials is lots of donations
in support of their ten dollars for
trials
five dollar five dollars from Lauren D
says SWAP SWAP SWAP
1000 DPR dude that sounds so [__] up
they'll talk about as it is stop it for
five dollars and just has a uh high five
emoji trials from Derek thank you twenty
dollar for swap
Jesus do you guys know that the I mean I
appreciate you all giving me money but
that
it's just I love it thank you guys swap
let's go trials gang where you at bust
down swapiana
somebody said three-way final if they're
tied a three-way final is not a terrible
idea yeah this is a way to resolve it
introduce uh
uh
all right listen this is too much you
guys it's still 50 50. it's 50 50.
here's what we're gonna do swap twenty
dollars thank you guys for all the
donations
their people are passionate in chat I
mean they are really I don't trust the
swappers oh no no no come on let's keep
it civil people they're interested
there is a hundred dollars hundred
dollars with no comments and they didn't
even yeah
mistakes were made so [__] I forgot
there is some skepticism coming from the
trials of Ethan folks uh uh suggesting
possibly some funny business
um oh okay here's what we're gonna do
then here's what we're gonna do
let's end it
we're gonna do three all three in the
final we're gonna do the three-way and
we're gonna watch all three okay and
then we're gonna vote okay and it's
gonna be one two three right there I
will say when I end if you see in the
chat I think it probably shows it
semifinals round two trials of Ethan 50
the swap 49. wait seriously yep
I'm not sending you the screenshot right
now right here I'll just pull it up for
real for real real
50 49 what happened to the one percent
I think that's just its way of letting
you know that this one does have more
votes than the other bro it's rigged
everything
that's a recount territory
there's the percent we're missing a
percent Dan
probably because it's 50.5 and 49.5 five
percent
[__]
I like the the three finalists you like
that idea it seems like the chat is uh
is liking the three-way idea so but that
almost
should we take a full uh poll in China I
don't feel it's fair to second place
because let's say everybody loves one
the second place one that a lot of
people might not might love is not maybe
is going to take votes but yeah it's
going to take votes from second place I
see what you're saying it might be an
upset
I think we've got weights and fish
I mean
you want to go to my letter of the law
the trials of Ethan was the winner of
that vote
ah but we were going to go to ten
thousand we didn't do that and then we
ended it early let's okay here's we're
gonna do we're gonna watch them on time
like you all have anything to do you're
watching this Friday night at 5 30 p.m
y'all got nothing to do come on let's
watch those two on times two speed and
then we're gonna vote again and I
guarantee you we're gonna come out with
a winner okay
all right all right thank you everybody
thank you for all the passion win or
lose definitely making a sequel AP
cinematography said
which one did he make
uh that's uh I believe that's trial oh
buddy right sitting on the edge of a
seat here
trials
all right so the two we're watching
we're watching is
the trials of Ethan and evil Biden or
wait no no no no in the swap the trials
of Ethan
Wow way to disrespect this no where's
the spot well it's not that's down the
dock is all [__] messy
where where's the other two down here
here's the trials this one right here
yeah
and the swap is right here
and you just not highlight the other
ones okay it's just fine all right let's
start with the swap we're gonna watch on
time what the [__] we're gonna watch on
times two speed
everybody focused Focus
wait this is on the Reddit player the
[__] can't do it on the red player there
goes that idea
let's just watch it you know in today's
society
we'll go through a lot of hard times
this is going to change how you see
everything join
joint on this journey
where am I am I this is beautiful
where's that screen
hey Granny get off the road you old hat
why do you hate me
I tell you what boy
oh comment on my property again you hear
me
[Music]
that [__] does a lot
Hey listen I got nothing to do with that
[Music]
dude that looks sick I wish I could just
wipe out the whole world of these
peasants as the executive chef of this
restaurant I would like to inform you we
took the body yo
chopped it up
and then you ate
God you're beautiful
look at me baby
[Music]
I have decided
I just like it
Who's Gonna Stop Me
I don't think so
all right
wow that's the swap guys the swap
and last time here the trials of Ethan
this is it Focus now
God damn it
here we go guys
should I do this one on times two I mean
it's not fair but you guys not fair you
think I gotta watch at normal speed all
right you didn't watch the other one I
didn't have a choice it shows obvious
favoritism
you don't want to be like this
this is disgusting this is awful in
every way that's disgusting I can't
believe you've even said that on YouTube
precisely
because such things matter when the
accusations start flying
we'll see who cancels
[Applause]
violate the Twitter rule
hey Ethan weird I've never seen you in
the prolapse Dimension I snorted too
much Alpha grind 9000 the effects are
similar to DMT it's pretty mellow listen
things seem pretty [__] up down there
the space-time Continuum has been a
little out of whack since
well wait are you eating chips Ethan
stop eating chips Ethan it's actually
it's wild right now I could be taking a
risk but I think you're our best shot at
this I'm sending you to a powerful
Oracle that can Aid you in your journey
of rebalancing the universe Jamie pull
up the quantum tunnel
[Music]
look at the size of that thing right
there holy smokes break the ladies
destitute of us
just not
[Music]
hey Stingray I'm gonna need your help
down here [__] totally brought it on
ourselves dude holy [__] we did we
[__] did
sons of [__] so you absorb the powers
of the chestnut Oracle did you I'll take
care of this beta mail I'm gonna squeeze
his [__] with my soft lips I mean fight
him with my name
it's got a [__] itchy [__] I'm
here to slaughter the children up yours
[__] these kids right if I could kill it
I would yeah I'm doing all I can no how
is this possible
[Music]
I know I have I know the winner now I
mean in my opinion I have a clear vote
okay am I uh going who was the last
winner hypothetically of the
the rigged one that was 49.50
trials one
the trials that's this one the one that
just ended okay
uh I just put up
the bull all right guys
get it in
we've watched them both
see this is what I'm saying when you
re-watch it it changes everything you
get to see it and I I gotta say the swap
is incredible for what it is but the
trials is
better I mean it's I I hate to use the
word better right because God bless you
all but the trials was a
It's A Cut Above
it's just something there you know
so there it is 65 isn't that interesting
a lot of people evidently you can't deny
that we were straight 50 50 and it is
now about two-thirds of the audience
breaks that is very and so there it is
where are you at now swap people
let's not denigrate them they were
already getting very sensitive earlier
Tucker said holy [__] you're still alive
yeah I get that I know that feeling
how long we've been going uh we've been
going for four hours in eight minutes
so let's call this trials bro Nobody
Does it Like Us and here let's keep the
momentum we just did trials so we don't
need to re-watch it huh we don't need to
re-watch right but let's quickly let's
pull up
um
let's pull up this one let's pull up um
Fly Me to the Moon all right we have our
finalists
um so congratulations to the swap you
got 30 you tied third place
wow this I think this is right we did
the right thing this these are both love
these both this is this is the match-up
So Fly Me to the Moon from beast from
space here it is
[Applause]
[Music]
dude a Nook sounds so good here
[Applause]
[Music]
through me
[Applause]
look at that sound the song is so dope
[Music]
[Applause]
over here
[Music]
I love you
this part of the song is incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
wow oh God
it blows my mind that both the finalists
had less than 100 upvotes on the Reddit
that's right yeah that's true is that
man I just again thank you and good job
Ian for making sure like these they
didn't fall through the we got the good
stuff we got not that it was all day but
all right final round pull shall I put
it up put it up so basically we've got
Fly Me to the Moon
burst
the trials
let me open trials real fast because I
actually I I can't I don't know what to
vote for
both feature a prominently a talking a
Nook head in space
this one had such good editing and I
mean they both did so defeating Jordan
Peterson with the cider oh and then this
joke gets me every time with the soft
lip
I mean with my nunchucks
but the song like this song in the other
one man I can't
well I gotta tell you do you have a vote
do you know who you voted for uh
um you don't have to tell frankly no
frankly no like I I don't really I don't
really favor one of these two it's a
coin toss for me these are both
excellent I was um
can I say who I voted for sure I I was
writing for Fly Me to the Moon like
since first round well that yeah yeah
the song Yeah song is powerful but then
like the trials of Ethan is like crazy
no it's insane yeah they're both insane
oh like the trials like has a whole like
narrative art like we go through a whole
journey like you're recruited by Joe I
think they want to get the powers and
then you you're [__] up you're taking
out the the Council of selei
the pacing was so good in the trials for
me the what the pacing yeah yeah it's
amazing oh and The Joe Rogan Odyssey
well have you have you not voted yet
have you not seen okay because I I will
tell you there is
it's I won't quite say a blowout but
somebody is the clear winner oh [__] yep
I didn't I couldn't it's not it's not as
close as I expected I would have
expected a tighter race here all right
I'm just gonna vote
huh
well Fly Me to the Moon seventy percent
it's I wonder though if it's just
because it's the most recent because
they're all amazing there's only so much
you can do like you watch it and you're
like that's amazing right but then if I
play the other one it might go the other
way like you saw how much
who can say who could say
this much of a gap I think I think it's
pretty clear to the Moon I voted for the
trials just because the Fly Me to the
Moon when I watched it I was like what's
better than this
but now looking through the timeline
there's just so much going on here yeah
that's surprising me because when you
were saying the original and the Fly Me
to the Moon was like nothing's gonna
beat that I had this one in mind like no
this one is going to be the one that
destroys it I was wrong I don't know
though there's a song it goes a long way
it really does and the song is is so
good in that one you know what that gets
you a lot of points it really does I
guess I agree that's disgust I mean and
they made that song too like in top of
the edit being great which it was yeah
the score Talent yeah pure talent and
like a Nook sounded like a star like an
angel
we were both compelled to say that at
the same time I actually want that song
in my playlist
well the people have spoken people have
spoken uh congratulations
what a tournament it's been the big the
champion
is
Austin FST
right no I'm sorry I just did a [__]
yeah you didn't move my mind and it's
called Fly Me to the Moon and you
moonlighted them Fly Me to the Moon bees
from space he's from space
who are you dude
God damn that was freaking insane
and not to take anything away from
Austin FST who made Trials of Ethan
which was like and apparently there's a
sequel coming too right if they said
there was a sequel I'm working on a
sequel uh we'll watch it guarantee that
it's gonna be like The Godfather Part
Two surpass the original probably and
then a tide for third place is Ethan
saves Palestine
and uh the Swap and the swap
but thank you to everyone as well
everyone on this list thank you so much
for your amazing work
that's the good ones we didn't even get
to show and so apologies if the years
didn't make it into the final bracket it
was a tough call on a lot of them but uh
lots of lots of fantastic special shout
out to Ethan on the playground that made
me giggle a lot what's wrong with that
it was you rolling around on the
playground and then you going like this
oh which one was that in the subreddit
it was called oh it's called the place
that's an honorable mention yes yes yes
ah
well congratulations guys uh we'll be in
touch with the winners
I want to give these guys a shout out
too if they have something to promote
punishment theaters they said Ethan I'm
always down to whip up whatever you want
thanks to everyone who showed love for
Ethan says Palestine videos on this
channel oh that's one of our Runners up
and you just gave us 50 Canadian dude
we're supposed to be paying oh I owe you
I owe you 100. what good is that
damn thank you man that so that's I'm
assuming
uh Reuben sandwich
was that the name of the yeah juicy
Reuben sandwich
well we have the best gosh darn
Community there is it's just so much
talent our ex-cat dad thank you for the
good Maggie sugar data to get it give
uh I feel sad I feel sad that all y'all
couldn't win man I really uh I'm gutted
but you got it for you got it for trials
I am I else but I'm so happy for Fly Me
to the Moon yeah yeah I love that in
fact let's [__] genius let's let him
play a song
because this song is everything yeah
well it's Friday happy Friday everyone I
hope you had a great week
we have anything special coming up uh
next week Dan
uh well leftovers will be back okay
which is gonna be fun Eddie's coming
back Monday and he'll be back on Monday
for another round Ethan won't be leaving
this time he's gonna hurt us no it was a
one-time
one-time deal
um yeah no
uh and we got some other stuff um
hopefully by Wednesday the button will
be fully operational
um
no promises we'll see how it goes it
depends on deliveries that I'm getting
so oh yeah next week will be our first
ever H3 lore
and they should lower stuff
that'll be fun
um thank you everybody have a great
weekend thanks for watching and thank
you especially to all the people who
made participated you guys are the best
thank you love y'all see you on Monday
have a great weekend
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my hands
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]